ORDER THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
NATIVE AMERICAN AFFAIRS AND THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING- AUGUST
EIGHTEENTH AT NINE THIRTY AM
WE'RE RUNNING A LITTLE BEHIND
BUT IT'S AN IMPORTANT ISSUE- A
MISSING AND MURDERED NATIVE
AMERICAN. PEOPLE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND- FOCUS ON
IMPLEMENTING AB THIRTY NINETY
NINE- LAW ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM
THAT WILL BRING POLICING- AND
RESOURCES TO TRAVEL COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO THANK ALL
THE PARTICIPANTS- THAT HAVE
MADE THE TIME TO TRAVEL EARLY
THIS MORNING TO BE HERE TO
TESTIFY TO THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
I WANT TO RECOGNIZE- FIRST OF
ALL THE TRIBAL AFFILIATIONS THE
HOMELANDS OF WHERE WE SIT AT
WITH THE ME WHAT NYSSA NON POT
WHEN. PEOPLE FROM THIS AREA.
THIS IS A JOINT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON NATIVE AMERICAN AFFAIRS. IN
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND CHAIR-
CRISTINA GARCIA OF THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS AND HER MEMBERS FOR
PARTNERING WITH US TODAY. LAST
YEAR BECAUSE OF THE SUPPORT OF
MANY IN THIS ROOM WE WERE ABLE
TO GET AB THIRTY NINETY NINE
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE AND
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR- LAST
SESSION. IT ADDRESSES A MAJOR
PUBLIC SAFETY EVENT ISSUE. ON
INDIAN RESERVATIONS AND NOT
ONLY LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
PARTICULAR- BUT NATIVE
AMERICANS- IN THE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE THERE AND THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE AMONG THE HIGHEST
REPRESENT A GROUP OF MISSING
AND MURDERED- PEOPLE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S
OUR NATIVE AMERICAN. SISTERS
BROTHERS AND CHILDREN SO BRING
IN THIS- FULL CIRCLE TO
HIGHLIGHTED NAVIGATED I WAS ONE
OF THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
ON HERE TODAY. AND WHAT THE
COMMITTEES THAT ARE FORMED HERE
FOR THIS INFORMATIONAL- HEARING
TO RAISE THE ADVOCACY OF WHAT'S
TRULY IS HAPPENING IN INDIAN
COUNTRY I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THAT. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN FOR EXAMPLE THE
NATIONAL CRIME INFORMATION
CENTER REPORTED THAT ABOUT 10%
OF THEIR TOTAL ENTRIES FOR THE
YEAR. APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE
WHO HAD NOT BEEN CLEARED. OF
THOSE EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED IN THAT GROUP THE
SECOND HIGHEST NUMBER OF
REPORTED MISSING PERSONS WERE
AMERICAN INDIANS ALASKA NATIVES
NATIVE HAWAIIANS. OR PACIFIC
ISLANDERS WHICH WERE ALL GROUP
TOGETHER AND THIS IS DSPITE
THE FACT THAT THEY MAKE UP THE
SMALLEST PORTION OF THE UNITED
STATES POPULATION. SO THAT
SHOULD SENT ALARMING DATA
STATISTICS OF WHY IN THAT AREA
THEY'RE AT THE HIGHEST SECOND
LEVEL THERE WHEN THEY'RE THE
LEAST HAVE THE LEAST POPULATION
IN THE UNITED STATES THERE'S A
PROBLEM GOING ON. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THE ISSUE ITSELF HAS
NOT RECEIVED AND SUSTAINED THE
ATTENTION THAT AS IF IT-DESERVES THAT IS WHY AT THE
URGING OF ADVOCATES IN THIS
ROOM AND IN PARTICULARLY
INCLUDING- FROM THE SEMI WHAT
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT- THE STUDENTS
AND THE YOUNG TRIBAL COUNCIL
THIS YEAR TODAY AND YOU'LL HEAR
FROM THEM. AS THEY- LOBBY TO
INTRODUCED AB THIRTY NINETY
NINE THE AVIC IT'S- FOR OUR
TRIBAL. WERE FIVE YOUNG
STUDENTS YOU'LL HEAR FROM THEM
SHORTLY. TWO YEARS AGO IN
AUGUST OF TWENTY NINETEEN AT
THE FIRST HEARING OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE. WE DISCUSSED A WIDE
RANGE OF ISSUES AFFECTING
CALIFORNIA'S NATIVE AMERICANS
ONE OF THOSE ISSUES WAS MISSING
AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS WOMEN.
AT THE TIME CALIFORNIA WAS
NUMBER SIX. ON THE TOP OF THE
TOP TEN LIST OF SATES WITH THE
HIGHEST NUMBER. OF MISSING AND
MURDERED INDIAN WOMEN AND GIRLS
AND CASES WITHIN THE SAN
FRANCISCO. AREA IT WAS IN THE
TOP TEN. THAT INFORMATION ALSO
CONTRIBUTED GREATLY TO WHY AB
THIRTY NINETY NINE WAS
INTRODUCED. AB THIRTY NINETY
NINE REQUIRES THE NEW PROGRAM
OVER A PERIOD OF FIVE YEARS
AMONG OTHER THINGS TO. DEVELOP
GUIDANCE FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
TRAINING ON POLICING AND
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS ON
TRIBAL LANDS CONSISTENT WITH
FEDERAL PUBLIC LAW EIGHTY THREE
TO EIGHTY REFERRED TO AS PUBLIC
LOT TO EIGHTY. PROVIDE
EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS GEARED
TOWARDS TRIBAL CITIZENS ABOUT
THE COMPLEXITIES OF CONCURRENT
CRIMINAL JURISDICTION INCLUDING
INFORMATION ABOUT VICTIMS
RIGHTS. AND THE SERVICES THAT
ARE AFFORDED TO THEM. SHARE
GUIDANCE ON IMPROVING CRIME
REPORTING CRIME STATISTICS
CRIMINAL PROCEDURES AND
INVESTIGATIVE TOOLS FOR PUBLIC
INVESTIGATIONS. FACILITATE AND
SUPPORT IMPROVE COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS. AND CONDUCT A
STUDY TO DETERMINE THE SCOPE OF
THE ISSUE OF MISSING AND
MURDERED NATIVE AMERICANS IN
CALIFORNIA. IDENTIFYING
BARRIERS TO REPORTING AND
ULTIMATELY ISSUING
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE THEY WILL COME BACK
TO THIS BODY WILL COME BACK TO
ALL OF US IN THE LEGISLATURE TO
FOLLOW THROUGH. THIS IS NOT
THAT AB THIRTY NINETY NINE WAS
APPROVED AND THAT'S THE STOP OF
THE WORK NO THIS IS THE
BEGINNING OF THE WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE AND WHAT THAT
STUDY COMING BACK TO US THAT
NOW THAT TWENTY GENERAL WILL BE
WELL EQUIPPED TO COMPLETE THAT
STUDY. THE LEGISLATURE WE'LL
TAKE IT FROM THERE AND MOVE
FORWARD ON PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT WOULD STRENGTHEN THAT AND
TO MAKE SURE THAT WILL PUBLIC
SAFETY IS SOMETHING FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA'S THAT WOULD INCLUDE
THE CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE.
ARE PRESENTERS WILL ADDRESS THE
ISSUES OF TRIBAL TRIBAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT COLLABORATION AMONG
VARIOUS AGENCIES VICTIM AND
FAMILY RIGHTS AND OBSTACLES TO
REDUCING RATES OF VIOLENCE IN
CASE RESOLUTION AND BEST
PRACTICES. THIS YEAR WE WERE
ALSO ABLE TO SECURE THROUGH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA'S
LEADERSHIP. AS CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY- BUDGET COMMITTEE FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS OVER A FIVE
YEAR PERIOD FOR AB THIRTY
NINETY NINE IMPLEMENTATION. AS
WE DEVOLVE INTO THE STATISTICS
AND HEAR THE STORIES OF FAMILY
MEMBERS WE ALSO ARE LEARNING
THAT A GROWING NUMBER OF YOUNG
MEN AND BOYS ARE ALSO AMONG THE
MISSING. AND MURDERED NATIVE
AMERICAN PEOPLE. THAT IS WHY
THAT WE ARE INCLUDING BOTH MEN
AND BOYS AS WE DISCUSS THESE
CASES. HISTORICALLY AND
CULTURALLY ISSUES ISSUES
HEAVILY IMPACTING THE CAUSES
RESULTS AND RESOLUTION OF
VIOLENCE ON TRIBAL LANDS HAVE
GONE FAR AND MANY TIMES NOT
EVEN INVESTIGATED YOU WILL
LEARN ABOUT THAT BACKGROUND AS
WE PROCEED TODAY IN THE FUTURE.
AND NOW IT'S MY GREAT HONOR TO
INTRODUCE MY COLLEAGUE THE
CHAIR OF THE WOMAN CAUCUS
CRISTINA GARCIA WHO HELPED IN
CHAMPION THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS GOING THROUGH HER
BUDGET COMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED. TO
FURTHER INVESTIGATE AND DEVELOP
THESE POLICIES WE JUST TALKED
ABOUT- CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU- MR
ON THE SHARE OF THOSE THE
AMERICAN CAUCUS- WE DON'T
REALLY WE'RE HERE TO ASSIST
MORE THAN ANYTHING APPLE BY THE
VOICE AS EVERYONE IN THE ROOM
HERE SO JUST EXCITED TO BE ABLE
TO BE A PARTNER. AND TO LEARN
AND FULL TRANSPARENCY THIS
ISSUE SHOULD HAVE BEEN ON THE
RADAR OF THE WOMEN'S CLUBS LONG
TIME AGO BUT I HAVE TO MEN AT
THE TOP THE WAY SHOULD HAVE
BEEN AND IT WAS UNTIL. ALL OF
YOU WITH MISTER RAMOS HAVE DONE
THE WORK TO HELP ELEVATE THIS
ISSUE AND EDUCATE US AND IT
REALLY SHOULDN'T BE UP TO YOU
TO DO THAT WORK BUT I DO WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THAT AND KNOW
THAT THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS. IS
COMMITTED TO BOTH LEARNING AND
GROWING AND ADVOCATING SIDE BY
SIDE WITH THE TOP OF AYE THOSE
VOICES- ALONG THE WAY AND SO I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU.
EXCITED THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
WORK WITH MR WRONG WITHIN THE
ADVOCATE TO SECURE THE FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET NO THAT HE'S BEEN- A
RELENTLESS ADVOCATE- OUT HERE
AND SO YOU HAVE A GREAT
REPRESENTATIVE AND HIM AS WELL.
AS THE CHAIR THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THEIR
EDUCATING BEYOND THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY THIS HAS TO
BE SOMETHING THAT WE ALL WORK
ON IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
REALLY WANTED SURE WE HAVE A
CALIFORNIA. THAT WORKS FOR ALL.
IN TWENTY TWENTY S. THAT HE
INDICATED THAT MORE THAN TWENTY
THREE MS MORE THAN TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED MISSING INDIGENOUS
WOMEN AND GIRLS. IN THE COUNTRY
ALTHOUGH IN THE CASE THAT
NEARLY HALF OF INDIGENOUS WOMEN
EXPERIENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
ON SOME RESERVATIONS ARE
MURDERED AT A RATE TEN TIMES
HIGHER. THAN THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE NONE OF US SHOULD HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO TELL THE STORIES
THAT WE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO SEE
HOW MY SISTER MY MOM MY AUNT.
HAS DISAPPEARED HAS BEEN
INJURED WITH THE REALITIES THAT
MANY IN OUR NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES HAVE THESE PERSONAL
STORIES. TO TELL. LIVE AT THIS
FROM US. CALIFORNIA SO TO MORE
THAN SEVEN. THE IN THE TO
PEOPLE. BUT THERE'S NO RELIABLE.
DATA ON EXACTLY HOW MANY
MISSING NATIVE WOMEN THERE
CURRENTLY ARE. WE HAVE VARIOUS
STUDIES OUT THERE BUT THE
NUMBERS. ARE INCOMPLETE AND
THAT DATA IS INCOMPLETE.
RELIABLE ACCURATE DATA IS
CRITICAL NOT ONLY TO UNDERSTAND
THE BREADTH OF THE PROBLEM. BUT
TO. SEIZE INDIVIDUALIZING THE
PLIGHT OF THE MISSING AND
MURDERED INDIGENOUS WOMEN. ONCE
WE HAVE THIS INFORMATION
COLLABORATION FEATURES TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
ACCURATE CREASE THE CHANCES
THAT CASES ARE. CAN BE RESOLVED
AND I WANT TO EMPHASIZE HOW
IMPORTANT COLLABORATION IS AND
THAT WE ARE THERE AS PARTNERS
LISTENING. AND WORKING AND
RESPECTING OUR NATIVE TRIBES
ALONG THE WAY. THE DOJ CAN PLAY
A CRITICAL ROLE IN ASSISTING
WITH THIS COLLABORATION AND
THAT'S WHY THIS FUNDING SO I'M
PORTED. ANDTHAT'S WHY THESE
HEARINGS ARE SO IMPORTANT HERE
AS WELL- I WANT TO ALSO APPLAUD
THE NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN WHO
ARE MAKING HISTORY LIKE. THAT
HOLLAND THE FIRST NATIVE
AMERICAN TO SERVE AS A CABINET
SECRETARY. JULIE PRO- PROBABLY
FIT THE FIRST INDIGENOUS WOMEN
ON THE COMMISSION ON THE STATUS
OF WOMEN AND GIRLS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND HOPEFULLY MANY
MURDERS ALL AND I HOPE BEFORE
MY TIME'S UP HERE THAT WE HELP
BRING SOME MORE COLLEAGUES US
THE MISTER RAMOS ISN'T ALONE.
AND THEN WE HAVE ELECT THE
FIRST NATIVE AMERICAN WOMAN TO
THE LEGISLATURE INTO THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS. I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF YOU FOR BEING HERE AND I
LOOK FORWARD. TO FINDING
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO
LEARNING WITH YOU AND FINDING
MORE WAYS TO BE AN ADVOCATE BY
YOUR SIDE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THIS TIME ANY-
COLLEAGUES ANY MEMBERS WITH AT
LEAST TO SAY ANYTHING.
MCCONNELL'S. MAJORITY LEADER.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN I ALSO WANT TO
ESCALATE THE COMMENTS OF OUR
TWO CHAIRS I THANK THEM FOR
CONVENING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
SELECT COMMITTEE. BUT I ALSO
WANT TO VERY SPECIFICALLY.
CONGRATULATE THE WOMEN THE
YOUNG WOMAN WHO ARE HERE WHO
ARE AT THE STRONGEST ADVOCATES
FOR THE MISSING AND MURDERED
INDIGENOUS WOMEN AND GIRLS IN
FACT BACK HOME THEY WERE
RECOGNIZED- AND AWARDED THIRTY
UNDER THIRTY- THAT'S- RAVEN
KHASAS ANNABELLA HERNANDEZ
DESTINY DOODLE. AND PRESLEY
CALDERON WHO HAVE WORKED
TIRELESSLY AND COURAGEOUSLY TO
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF THOSE
AFFECTED I THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE AND I. CONTROL ALL OF YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS INSERTED IN
THE BOOK THAT YOU RECEIVED.
ABSOLUTE MORE ABOUT THEM AND I
CONGRATULATE THEM AGAIN. THANK
GOODNESS DETER THANK YOU AMANDA
MAJORITY LEADER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER. I JUST WANT TO CHECK
WITH PICKETERS CHAIR ALMOST
ENSURE GARCIA- FOR BRING THIS
FORWARD- MISTER RAMOS IS A
CHAMPION OF NATIVE AMERICAN
RIGHTS HE'S BEEN A CHAMPION
FROM DAY ONE THIS TIME THE
LEGISLATURE. AND WHAT I REALLY
LIKE ABOUT- THE BILL THAT THE
TROUBLES BEFORE IT IS THAT THE
FUNDING HELPED TRAIN LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE DOJ IS
OBVIOUSLY STATEWIDE BUT YOUR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT IT'S
GONNA BE THEN INDIVIDUALS THAT
INVESTIGATED CASES. THEIR BOOTS
ON THE GROUND THEY KNOW THE
AREA- IDEALLY SO- IN THE
TRAINING SUPPORT AND WE SEE IT
SO MUCH I KNOW MISTER C. HAS
BEEN A CHAMPION OF WOMEN'S
RIGHTS. OVER THE YEARS
CONTINUES TO FIGHT TO ENSURE
THAT WOMEN- RETREAT IS EQUAL SO
I'M EXCITED OUTSIDE HERE SOME
TESTIMONY TODAY I FEEL WE CAN
HELP OUR NATIVE AMERICAN.
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA SO THANK
YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER. AT
THIS TIME WE WANT TO MOVE- AND
WE'RE GONNA CALL ON THE- THE
YOUNG LADIES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WHAT TROUBLE GOVERNMENT- TO BE
ABLE TO PERFORM TO PRESENT
THEIR TESTIMONY- AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU- ALSO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA CHAIRWOMAN. FOR ALL YOUR
WORK IN ADVOCACY WORKING
TOGETHER ON THESE ISSUES NOW
YOU'LL HEAR FROM THE STUDENTS
WHO CAME WHO CAME TO ME AS AN
ADVOCATE AND ASKED TO WORK ON
THIS ISSUE. THERE ARE ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SEVEN WILD
TRAVEL GOVERNMENT. AND MEMBERS
OF THE YOUTH COMMITTEE FROM
WITHIN OUR TRAVEL GOVERNMENT.
AND ARE DEEPLY COMMITTED TO
ENDING THIS TRAGIC CYCLE OF
VIOLENCE. ALL THREE ARE ELECTED
MEMBERS OF THE SEVEN WHILE
YOUTH COMMITTEE. AND BROUGHT
FORWARD RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES. THE R.
RAVEN CLASSES. PRESLEY
CALDERON. ANNABELLA HERNANDEZ.
AND THEY WERE ALSO JOINED AT
EARLIER- SELECT COMMITTEE
HEARING- LAST YEAR OR THE YEAR
BEFORE- WERE MISS DESTINY GIRL-
OFFERS- TESTIMONY. ALSO SHE
WASN'T ABLE TO BE HERE TODAY
WITH US BUT THEY ARE DEEPLY
ENGAGED. IN NOT ONLY THE ISSUE
OF MISSING EMERGES WOMEN BUT
ISSUES ARE AFFECTING- THE
INDIAN PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- THEY WILL SHARE HOW
THEIR ADVOCACY AFFECTED THEM
PERSONALLY. AND THEIR
DIFFERENCE- THAT THEY BELIEVE
THEY ARE HELPING TO CREATE. AND
LASTLY THEY WILL SHARE THEIR
EXPERIENCE IN WORKING WITH THE
ASSEMBLY. TO GET AB THIRTY NINE
I'M PASSED. ON A THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ACTIVISM- ON BEHALF OF THE
SEMINOLE TRIBAL GOVERNMENT- WE
DO HAVE COUNCIL MEMBERS THAT
ARE HERE AND VICE CHAIRS THAT
ARE HERE. I'M YOU'LL HEAR FROM
CHAIRWOMAN- FROM. ANOTHER TRIBE
HERE LATER ON BUT I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT A YOUNG AGE
TAKING UP THE MANTLE. TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES. AND YOU
SEE THE BODY IN FRONT OF YOU
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
ALWAYS. WANT TO ENCOURAGE THAT
IF YOU'RE- ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD
IN THIS ROUND NOW THERE'S NO
REASON. ANYONE OF YOU CAN'T SIT.
IN THE SEATS THAT WERE CERTAIN
AND NOW. THE ENOUGH FOR. THAT
STANDS IN FRONT OF OUR PEOPLE.
SO WE WANT TO GO HEAD TO MOVE
FOR WITH THE PRESENTATION I'M
NOT SURE. I KNOW YOU WORKED OUT
AMONGST YOURSELF WHO WILL GO
FIRST AND THE SECOND GO THIRD.
BUT THE PRESENTERS WILL BE-
RAVEN CLASSES. PRESLEY CALDERON
AND ANNABELLA HERNANDEZ. SO
WHO'S GOING FIRST. OUR GROWTH
RAVEN CLASS FIRST- GOOD MORNING
TO RAMOS SURE WOMAN GARCIA
COMMITTEE CAUCUS MEMBERS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DISCUSS WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED
ABOUT. PEOPLE AND THE
SUBSEQUENT. AGAINST BOB
CALIFORNIA COMPENSATION THAT. I
THANK THEM VERY. HELLO EVERYONE
MY NAME IS PROCESS. NINE WELL.
WE ARE WORKING RIGHT. IN TWENTY
NINETY I ATTENDED A NEED YOUTH
IN FOR AND DURING THE COMP I
FOR WENT INTO TO. THIS ALSO
MOVEMENT BRINGS TO THE EFFORT
OF AND JUST THAT WOMEN GIRLS
AND PEOPLE. NEEDHAM WOMEN ARE
TEN TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BE OR
SEXUAL ASSAULT THEM ANY OTHER
AT GROUP. BUT SPOKE TO PER AND
I FELT THE NEW TO BRING WHAT I
LEARNED TO MY OWN TYPE OF. MY
COUSINS AND I WOULD FROM
CONFERENCE IN. TO BRING THE
ISSUE. TRAVEL LEADERS THEY WERE
VERY RESPONSIVE AND SUPPORTIVE
TO OUR REQUEST AND HELPED US
FIND DIFFERENT PLATFORMS WE
NEEDED TO START SPREADING
AWARENESS. ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT PEOPLE THAT WE LOOK
TO FOR SUPPORT WAS SEVEN WAS
CHIEF JUDGE THE LATE CLAUDETTE
WHITE. SHE SHARED HER KNOWLEDGE
AND PERSONAL STORY ON THE
TRAUMA THIS ISSUE HAD CAUSED
NOT ONLY TO HER BUT HER FAMILY.
I WANT TO THANK HER FOR HER
MENTORSHIP GUIDANCE AND CARE
SHE WILL FOREVER LIVE ON IN MY
HEART. ONE OF OUR FIRST EFFORTS
WAS FLYING TO SACRAMENTO TO
BRING UP BEFORE YOU AND OTHER
ELECTED OFFICIALS. WE WANTED TO
SEE HOW WE CAN PARTNER TOGETHER
TO FIND LEGISLATIVE SOLUTIONS
TO THE JURISDICTIONAL ISSUES
THAT FUEL THIS PROBLEM. WE ARE
SPECIALLY THING FOR THE SENATE
ASSEMBLY MEN RAMOS WHO MET WITH
US AND DECIDED TO INTRODUCED AB
THIRTY NINETY NINE AND TWENTY
TWENTY. AT THAT TIME WE KNEW
OUR OUR EFFORTS FOR GETTING THE
ATTENTION THAT THEY DESERVED.
I'M JOINED TODAY BY SEVEN WAS
YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANNABELLA
HERNANDEZ AND PARTIALLY
CALDERON TO SHARE THEIR OWN
PERSPECTIVE ON OUR EFFORTS
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO MY
STORY. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
THE- NEXT WE HAVE ANNABELLA
HERNANDEZ. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN RAMOS CHAIRMAN GARCIA
COMMITTEE AND CAUCUS MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ANABEL HERNANDEZ AND
I'M A FOURTEEN YEAR OLD TRIBAL
CITIZEN FROM THE SAN MANUEL
BAND OF MISSION INDIANS. WHEN I
FIRST LEARNED ABOUT M. I. W. P.
THE MIX OF EMOTIONS WENT
THROUGH MY BODY I FELT SAD
ANGRY AND A SENSE OF
RESPONSIBILITY TO GET ENGAGE
WITH MY TRIBAL COMMUNITY. IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN ALONE
THERE WERE FIVE THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED TWELVE MURDERED AND
MISSING INDIGENOUS WOMEN AND
GIRLS REPORTED THE ONLY A
HUNDRED SIXTEEN WERE LOGGED IN
THE U. S. DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE'S DATABASE. EVERY YEAR.
EVERY YEAR ARE TRY POST THE
POWER WHILE THIS GATHERING OF
NATIONS BRINGS TOGETHER
THOUSANDS OF NATIVE AMERICANS
AND THE GENERAL PUBLIC. TO
SOCIALIZE COMPETE AND HONOR OUR
CULTURES. DURING OUR TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN POWER WHILE
WE INCLUDED A RED DRESS SPECIAL
DANCE COMPETITION AN
INFORMATIONAL BOOTH AND RAISE
FUNDS FOR THE SOVEREIGN BODIES
INSTITUTE. OUR GOAL WAS TO
CREATE A SPACE FOR THOSE THAT
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED OR KNOW OF
OTHERS THAT HAVE. ALL THE WOMAN
THAT ATTENDED THE COMPETITION
DANCED INSERT STOOD IN
SOLIDARITY. WE ASKED EVERYONE
TO WEAR RED DRESSES IN HONOR OF
MY W. P. AFTER THE COMPETITION
THE WINNER CAME UP TO US AND
THANKED US FOR THE WORKSHOP WE
HAD DONE SHE SHARED HOW THE
GIRL HOW A GIRL WITHIN HER OWN
FAMILY WAS LOST AND SPOKE OF
THE STRUGGLES THEY UNDER. SHE
ALSO SHARED HOW GRATEFUL SHE
WAS FOR THE VISIBILITY
VISIBILITY WE WERE GIVEN.
GIVING THOSE WHO HAD BEEN LOST
AND HOW FAR THIS ISSUE HAS COME
OVER THE YEARS. IT IS STORIES
AND MOMENTS LIKE THE ONE WE
SHARE THE POWER OUT THAT PUSHED
ME FORWARD ON THIS JOURNEY. AS
A GROUP WE MADE A COMMITMENT TO
FURTHER EDUCATE OTHERS ABOUT
THE HARDSHIPS BEING EXPERIENCED
IN INDIAN COUNTRY. I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE LATE JACQUE JUDGE
WIFE. FOR SHARING HER PERSONAL
STORY AND HOW THIS MOVEMENT HAD
PERSONALLY IPACTED HER. SHE
MADE US FEEL HEARD AND
CONNECTED US TO MMI W. P. SHE
WAS THEIR MENTORING US EVERY
STEP OF THE WAY UP UNTIL HER
PASSING. IN PASSING AB THIRTY
NINETY NINE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS ALSO SHOWN ITS
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE AND
ADDRESSING THE LEGISLATIVE.
NEEDS TO COMBAT THE AND MY WPF
ATOMIC. THANK YOU FOR LISTENING
TO MY STORY HOW COOPER I AM A
U. OF T. HAKUBA. THEY YOU-
ANIME HERNANDEZ RIGHT UP
PRESENTER PRESS THE POUND ON.
HOW COULD I CAN MAKE. I HEY AGO
AMMA. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN RON
CHAIRWOMAN. AND COMMITTEE
COMEDIAN KAKA MEMBERS. THE TWO
ONE PRESSING CALDERON A TIME
WORTH MY TO PULL A LOT A THE
NEW HAVE YOUTH. MANY IS
PRESSING CAL AND THEN THE FORTY
YEAR OLD CITIES FROM THE SALMON
WILL BAND IN. I AM ONE OF THE
NEWEST MEMBERS THE TASK FORCE
WE CREATED. AFTER THEIR TRIP TO
FLORIDA MICHAEL SHARE HOW THE
WERE IN BY THE ISSUE. I NEW
MEDIA I WANTED TO GET INVOLVED
AND MAKE A DIFFERENCE. DURING
MEETINGS WITH TRIBAL LEADERS
AND STAFF. WE DECIDED TO
IMPLEMENT. A COMPREHENSIVE PUFF
PUBLIC FACING CAMPAIGN TO DRIVE
AWARENESS OF THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. THIS INCLUDED A
COMMERCIAL WE FILMED FOR KTLA
FIVE LAST NOVEMBER FIVE
BILLBOARDS ALONG SOME OF THE
MOST TRAVELED FREEWAYS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND A
WEBSITE FULL OF INFORMATION
SURROUNDING MMA W. P. WE ARE
ALSO FEATURED IN A NEW MAGAZINE
THAT OUR TRIBE RECENTLY
LAUNCHED THE FIRST ISSUE OF
HANINA MAGAZINE HAS A FOUR PAGE
ARTICLE WITH INFORMATION ABOUT
MMA W. P. AND THE WAYS WE HAVE
WORKED TO BRING AWARENESS OF
THIS ISSUE. WE HOPE TO FURTHER
EDUCATE EVERYONE ABOUT MMI W.
P. AND PROVIDE RESOURCES FOR
ADVOCATES AND THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THAT HAVE BEEN AFFECTED
PERSONALLY. I WAKE UP INSPIRED
EACH AND EVERY DAY BY THIS
MOVEMENT WE ARE NOT A WE ARE
NOW PART OF. I WANT TO CONTINUE
USING MY VOICE TO EDUCATE EVEN
MORE PEOPLE AND HELP PREVENT
VIOLENCE AND JUSTICE FOR NATIVE
AMERICANS. WE ARE HERE TODAY
WITH THE SUPPORT FROM OUR TRIBE
I LEADERS AND TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES STAND WITH US ON
THIS JOURNEY TO FIND CREATIVE
WAYS TO RAISE AWARENESS AT HOME
AND IN THE WIDER COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE WHO
HELPED PASS AB T. ZERO NINE
NINE AND SIGNED INTO LAW LAST
YEAR. WE ARE GLAD THAT THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
VIEW THIS ISSUE AS WE DO A
HUMAN ISSUE. YOU ALL SHOULD
THAT SUPPORT WHEN THIS BILL
PASSED WITHOUT A SINGLE VOTE NO.
THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY WOMAN
REYES FOR RECOGNIZING US FOR
THE THIRTY UNDER THIRTY ANNUAL
AWARD. WINNING THAT AWARD WAS
IN NEW AND GREAT EXPERIENCE FOR
US. MORE THAN JUST SALMON WAS
CHIEF JUDGE SHE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN GETTING US TO
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW. SHE
DEVOTED HER PERSONAL TIME TO
MANY OF THE EFFORTS WE HAVE
SPOKEN TO YOU ABOUT TODAY.
JUDGE WHITE WAS NO STRANGER TO
US AND WE FELT COMFORTABLE
TALKING TO HER BETTER IDEAS SHE
WILL FOREVER HAVE A SPECIAL
PLACE IN MY HEART. WE HOPE YOU
ARE INSPIRED TO STAND WITH US
WE ASK THAT YOU CONTINUE OUR
WORK BY ENGAGING AND EDUCATING
ARE YOUR COMMUNITIES ABOUT MMA
DEBBIE P. WE APPRECIATE THE
TIME YOU ARE COMMITTING TO THIS
ISSUE. AND I'M EXCITED TO SEE
THE CHANGES THAT AS- THAT COME
AS WE MOVE FORWARD TOGETHER.
I'M AYE THAT IS ALL. COOPER HAD
TO FIVE. THE THEM THIS GOOD THE-
HEAR THE TESTIMONY AND- HAVE
CULTURE AND THE LANGUAGE MAKES
IN THERE AND- JUDGE WHY RESTER
SO WE DID- AMEND AB TEN FIFTY
FIVE IT NOW IS CALLED THE JUDGE
WHITE- ACT AND IT'S FOR FOSTER
CARE KIDS. THAT'S CURRENTLY ON
THE SENATE AND APPROACH WE'RE
HOPING TO GET THAT RELEASED
HERE MR WE CONTINUE TO SEE THAT
ADVOCACY MOVING FORWARD WITH
FOSTER CARE I THANK THE
MAJORITY LEADER AND RECOGNITION
OF THE THIRTY UNDER THIRTY THAT
WAS MENTIONED WE SHARE SAMBAR
DINO BUT WE SHARE MORE THAN
THAT WE SHARE THE HISTORY THE
CULTURE OF SAMBAR DINO WHAT HAS
MADE IT WHAT IT IS TODAY. AND
CERTAINLY THE PEOPLE OF SANTA'S
BEEN WELL I WITHIN THAT ROUND
ON AT THIS TIME I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND YOUR
CONTINUED BAD ADVOCACY MANY
ISSUES AFFECTING INDIAN PEOPLE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WE'RE NOW LOOKING AT BOARDING
SCHOOLS INVESTIGATION OF
BOARDING SCHOOLS WERE LOOKING
AT- THE AB THREE THREE EIGHT
THAT WOULD REPLACE A STATUE
HERE ON THE GROUNDS OF JUDAH
PERO SERRA AND RECOGNIZE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE FROM THE
LOCAL AREA. THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS THAT WERE WORKING ON
INDIAN EDUCATION IN PARTICULAR
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COLLEAGUES THAT ARE HERE ARE
DEEPLY ENGAGED WITH US TO MAKE
SURE THAT CHANGE IN THAT VOICE
OF ALL CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE
IS BEING HEARD I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ADVOCACY. AND FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY THIS MORNING
THANK YOU. CRISTINA. THANK YOU
AS WELL- IT ALWAYS IS IN A LOT
OF HOPE FOR THE FUTURE AND WE
SEE SENATORS- TAKING CHARGE AND
ADVOCATING BE THE CHANGE INTO
THAT WE NEED. WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO OUR NEXT- PRESENTATION.
LAST MONTH GOVERNOR NEWSOM
APPOINTED DR PROFIT TO THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS
BEGINNER THE FIRST INDIGENOUS
WOMEN TO SERVE IN THAT ROLE.
PROFESSOR DR JOLIE PROFIT HAS
BEEN TEN YEARS THREE TIMES IN
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
SHE HAS SERVED AS THE AMERICAN
INDIAN STUDIES CHAIR AND THAT
THE DOCTOR THE CALIFORNIA
INDIAN CULTURE AND SEVENTEEN
CENTER. DR PROFIT IS ABOUT
BECAUSE HE MEMBER AT THE CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY SAN MARCOS AS
PROGRAM COORDINATOR FOR NATIVE
STUDIES AND IS DEPARTMENTS.
CHAIR OF THE NEWLY ESTABLISHED
AMERICAN INDIAN STUDIES
DEPARTMENT. IN ADDITION SHE IS
THE FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ANNUAL
CALIFORNIA'S AMERICAN INDIAN
AND INDIGENOUS FILM FESTIVAL.
WELCOME DR JULIE PROFIT. SURE
WE JOINING BY ZOOM SO HOPEFULLY
THAT. WE DON'T SEE ANYTHING
THERE NOW. DO WE HAVE ANYBODY
ON ON THE ZOOM. IS VIRGINIA
HENDRICK ON. NOW DO WE HAVE A.
WE'RE IN PERSON K. WILL GO
AHEAD AND MOVE TO THAT ONE WELL
WE TRY TO FIGURE OUT THE NEXT.
THAT WORKS TO WILL WILL I JUST
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND YOUR UNDERSTANDING- WE WILL
ADJUST AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT PIECEON CURRENT FEDERAL
AND TRIBAL ADVOCACY EFFORTS. WE
WILL HEAR FROM VIRGINIA
HENDRICK EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM UP
FOR URBAN AND INDIAN HEALTH.
THE C. C. U. I. H. AS THE
MEMBER ORGANIZATION COMPOSED OF
TEN URBAN INDIAN HEALTH
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. MS HENDRICK IS A
MEMBER OF THE YUROK TRIBE. WE
WILL ALSO HAVE WITH HER APRIL
MIKE GILL WHO IS THE DIRECTOR
OF COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS AND
PROJECTS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM. FOR URBAN INDIAN
HEALTH. MIXMAG JILL MCGILL IS
YUKI WAFFLE THE LAKE COMO AND
WHITEY WHITEY. LACKEY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. THEY WILL
SPEAK ABOUT THE COMMUNITY IN
THE CONSORTIUMS THAT THE
COMMUTER THE CONCESSION SERVICE
AND WHAT THEY HAVE LEARNED FROM
THEIR PROGRAMS AND COMMUNITY
SERVICE. WELCOME TO BOTH MISS
HENDRICK IN THIS MODULE WE MUCH
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
SQUAREPOINT ACT NOT VIRGINIA
HEDRICK SHOWING ON MY WILL
MATCH UP NOT PELUK LAW. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS VIRGINIA
HEDRICK. I COME FROM THE
VILLAGE OF STRIKE ON ON THE
KLAMATH RIVER REMEMBER THE
YUROK TRIBE. AND SERVE AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM FOR URBAN
INDIAN HEALTH. HAS BEEN MORE
THAN EIGHTEEN YEARS OF MY LIFE
LIVING IN AN URBAN SETTING.
INCLUDING LOS ANGELES AND NOW
SACRAMENTO. WHERE I RAISED FIVE
CHILDREN. THREE BOYS AND TWO
GIRLS TWO OF WHICH COME TO MY
HOME THROUGH THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. I UNDERSTAND THE
STRUGGLES OF LIVING IN BOTH THE
RURAL AREA. GROWING UP WITHOUT
ELECTRICITY. AND NOW LIVING
HERE IN THE CAPITAL CITY. THE
COOLEY IS A POLICY ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION. BASED AND
SUPPORTING OUR URBAN INDIAN
ORGANIZATIONS AND SOME OF
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST CITIES OF
WHICH THERE ARE TEN. WE HAVE
SIX. OF CLINICS INCLUDING THAT
PROVIDE MEDICAL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DENTAL. AND WE ALSO
INCLUDE TO RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT FACILITIES AN EIGHTY
BED FACILITY IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND A SIXTEEN BED ALL MAIL
FACILITY. AT IN. MANTECA
CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO
APPRECIATE THAT THE TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS COUNTS FOR
CALIFORNIA INCLUDE ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION AMERICAN INDIANS
AND ALASKA NATIVES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT REPRESENTS
15% OF OUR ENTIRE NATION'S
POPULATION RESIDE IN THE GREAT
STATE OF WHAT IS NOW KNOWN AS
CALIFORNIA. IN TWENTY TEN. 90%
OF THOSE AMERICAN INDIANS WERE
IDENTIFIED AND LIVING AND
CALIFORNIA'S URBAN SETTINGS.
THE ISSUE OF CALIFORNIA INDIAN
COUNTRY IS NOT LIMITED TO ONLY
RESERVATION LAND IN FACT THE
ENTIRE STATE IS INDIGENOUS
TERRITORY. NO MATTER WHERE YOU
STAND IN CALIFORNIA YOU ARE
STANDING AND TRIBAL TERRITORY I
APPRECIATE THE LAND OF
KNOWLEDGE MEANT THIS MORNING
RAMOS IN AN APPRECIATING THAT
EVEN HERE IN THE CAPITAL CITY
WE ARE ON UNCEDED TERRITORY.
SPEAKING OF DATA I WANT
APPRECIATE THE MANY STATISTICS
THAT HAVE BEEN SHARED THAT SHOW
THE GRAVITY OF THE SITUATION
THAT BRINGS US HERE THIS
MORNING. I ALSO WANT TO
APPRECIATE AS AN INDIGENOUS
PERSON BUT ALSO LIVES IN THIS
WESTERN WORLD. THE WESTERN
WORLD TELLS US THAT WE HAVE TO
SHOW NUMBERS WE HAVE TO SHOW
DATA. TO SHOW THAT IT'S A
PROBLEM. TO ADVOCATE FOR
FUNDING BUT AS INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE ONE WOMAN. ONE SISTER
ONE MAN ONE GRANDMOTHER IS TOO
MANY. THE RELATIVES WHO SPOKE
BEFORE ME SPOKE OF I WALK CHIEF
JUSTICE. NOT ONE LOSS WILL HAVE
A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT IN THE
TRAJECTORY OF US AS INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE. ONE OF MY CHILDHOOD
FRIENDS MOTHER WENT MISSING IN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE. HER NAME
WAS ANDRE A CHECK WHITE. SHE
HAS NOT LIVED HER LIFE IN LINE
AND HAVE CHILDREN. AND HER
BROTHERS AND SISTERS HAVE
CHILDREN WITHOUT THEIR MOTHER
PRESENT OUR ENTIRE LIVES. WE
KNEW HER MOTHER WAS MISSING.
EVERY PLACE WE TRAVEL TO PLAY
BASKETBALL AND VOLLEYBALL AND
R. THREE SEASONS OF SPORTS. WE
ALWAYS LOOK FOR HER MOTHER.
THAT'S JUST ONE STORY THAT
IMPACTS THAT COMMUNITY MORE
WOMEN HAVE GONE MISSING FROM
THAT VALLEY. SO WE CAN TALK
ABOUT THE THOUSANDS BUT ONE IS
TOO MANY. TO THE POINT OF DATA
CALIFORNIA SUFFERS ONE OF THE
HIGHEST RATES OF RACIAL MISS
CLASSIFICATION THAT MEANS AS
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE WE ARE OFTEN
IDENTIFIED BY ANOTHER RACE. AND
WE HAVE A HISPANIC SURNAME WE
MAY BE MISIDENTIFIED WHICH
STEMS FROM A LONG HORRIFIC
HISTORY RELATED TO THE MISSION
IS ATION OF CALIFORNIA. IF WE
PHENOTYPICALLY APPEAR WHITE WE
WILL BE IDENTIFIED AS WHITE. IF
WE APPEAR MARC MULTIRACIAL WE
WILL BE CATEGORIZED IN A MULTI
RACE CATEGORY AND THEREFORE
ERASED FROM PRESENT DATA. WE
ARE QUITE LITERALLY BORN INDIAN
AND DYING WHITE. THE ISSUE OF
MURDERED MISSING NATIVE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IS ONE THAT IS
SERIOUSLY UNDERCOUNTED. SO WE
THINK THE SITUATION IS GRAVE
TODAY IMAGINE THE MANY LIVES
WHO ARE NOT IN THE DATA CHARTS
OR NOT REPRESENTED THERE. FOR
THE REASONS THAT I JUST SHARED.
I WANT APPRECIATION THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING US TO JOIN TODAY I
DON'T WANT TO TAKE TOO MUCH
TIME FROM THE PANEL BECAUSE I'M
SO HONORED TODAY TO BE SITTING
NEXT TO MY COLLEAGUES. ABRE
MCGILL WHO DOES THIS HARD WORK
ON BEHALF OF OUR COMMUNITY. OUR
ORGANIZATION IS HOME TO A
STATEWIDE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
MMI W. NETWORK CALLED THE RED
WOMAN RISING PROJECT AND I'LL
SEE THE REST OF MY TIME TO MISS
MCGILL. WE ARE THANK YOU MY
NAME'S APRIL MCGILL- I JUST
WANT TO RECOGNIZE. THE
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE- OF THIS
TERRITORY. AND THE LIVES THAT
WERE TAKEN AND MURDERED MISSING
FROM THIS AREA- I AM VERY
HUMBLE TODAY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
ABOUT THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE.
FOR THE RED WOMAN RISING
PROJECT. THE RED WOMAN RISING
PROJECT STARTED FIVE YEARS AGO
AND IT WAS REALLY TO BRING
ATTENTION TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
IN CALIFORNIA. BOTH IN OUR
URBAN AND TRIBAL COMMUNITIES.
THE COOLEY HAS WORKED REALLY
HARD TO CREATE A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. A NETWORK THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WE WORK REALLY
CLOSELY WITHIN OUR NETWORK IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND LOCALLY
HERE IN SAN FRANCISCO WELL I'M
WE'RE IN SACRAMENTO BUT IN SAN
FRANCISCO WHERE I LIVE. I'M A
RESIDENT OF SAN FRANCISCO A
TRIBAL PERSON AND URBAN NATIVE
AND I WORK A LOT WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY SAN FRANCISCO HAS HAD
A LOT OF MISSING AND MURDERED
INDIGENOUS WOMEN WE HAVE ONE OF
THE HIGHEST. IN CALIFORNIA. THE
WORK THAT I DO IS VERY
PERSONAL. WE HAVE LOST OUR
SISTERS HERE THAT WERE IN OUR
COMMUNITY DUE TO VIOLENCE. UGH.
WE MAKE SURE THAT THE VICTIMS
AND NOT THOSE SURVIVORS VOICES
ARE HEARD AND THAT THEIR
STORIES ARE TOLD THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE DO IS CREATE DIGITAL
STORIES FOR OUR SURVIVORS WE
OFFER THAT AS A TEACHING TOOL
IT'S ONE THAT HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE AS NATIVE
PEOPLE WE KNOW THAT WERE OLD
TRADITIONAL PEOPLE THAT WE TELL
OUR STORIES THAT'S HOW WE
LEARNED THAT'S HOW WE PASSED ON
TRADITION. AND THAT'S HOW WE
TEACH OUR YOUNG WOMEN TO BE
SAFE. SO WE PROVIDE ACCESS TO
OUR TRADITIONAL HEALERS AS WELL
WE KNOW THAT. A LOT OF OUR
WOMEN CANNOT JUST GO TO A
CLINIC AND GET. OF PROFESSIONAL
HELP THEY WANT TO SEE A
TRADITIONAL PERSON SOMEBODY
THAT LOOKS LIKE THEM THAT CAN
PROVIDE CEREMONY THAT CAN GIVE
THEM THE HEALING THAT THAT THEY
NEED. SO COOLEY HAS WORKED VERY
HARD WITH OUR ALLIES THROUGHOUT
SAN FRANCISCO THE WORK THAT I
DO IN SAN FRANCISCO IS REALLY
WITHIN. OF THE MAYOR'S OFFICE
IN THE CITY AND COUNTY FOLKS
THERE. WE WERE ABLE TO CREATE
AN MMI W. RESOLUTION IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TO MAKE MAY FIFTH. MMI
W. AWARENESS DAY. THIS CAME
ABOUT BECAUSE OF OUR SISTER
JESSICA ALBA JESSICA ALL WAS
MURDERED IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
SHE WAS MISIDENTIFIED SHE WAS
NOT. IDENTIFIED AS BEING NATIVE
THAT WAS THE FIRST THING THAT
SIMILAR TO WHAT VIRGINIA SHARED
EARLIER ABOUT OUR WOMEN. SO WE
DECIDED THAT WE NEED TO WORK
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND SAN
FRANCISCO SO WE CREATED AN
AMERICAN INDIAN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE TO THE SAN FRANCISCO
POLICE DEPARTMENT. TO MEET
REGULARLY AND TALK ABOUT
IDENTIFYING OUR NATIVE WOMEN
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT. IN URBAN
COMMUNITY WE LOOK- LIGHT WE
LOOK DARK WE HAVE YOU KNOW WE
HAVE MANY- WE DON'T JUST FIT
INTO ONE STEREO TYPE. AND SO
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO- LOOK AT.
OTHER POLICE OFFICERS WHO ARE
NATIVE IN THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
TO WORK WITH US AND PARTNER
WITH US. WE ALSO OF HAVE MET
WITH THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE ABOUT THE JESSICA ALL
THIS CASE. BECAUSE SHE WAS
MISIDENTIFIED AND HER CASE WAS
NOT HANDLED CORRECTLY BUT THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY BOUTIN WAS
WILLING TO HEAR OUR STORY AND
TO HEAR FROM HER MOTHER AND HER
FAMILY. ABOUT HER CASE AND SO
THAT RIGHT THERE OPENS UP A
DOOR FOR AMERICAN INDIAN.
FAMILIES WHO WHO HAVE LOST
LOVED ONES TO BUILD THESE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEM LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITHIN OUR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. OF IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
RECEIVING TRAINING FROM OUR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ADVOCATES
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE EXPERTS
AND THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO
TRAIN. AROUND CULTURALLY
COMPETENT PROTOCOLS THAT WE
HAVE WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES.
ONE EXAMPLE I WANT TO SHARE IT
WAS IN TWENTY NINETEEN IN SAN
DIEGO I WAS ADVOCATING FOR AND
MURDER NATIVE SISTER WHO I DID
NOT KNOW BUT WAS MURDERED AND
SAN DIEGO. HER FAMILY WAS
ORIGINALLY FROM MONTANA AND SHE
WAS CHAYANNE AND- WE WENT TO
THE POLICE THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT TO GET INFORMATION
ON HER AUTOPSY WHICH WE WERE.
NOT ALLOWED TO HAVE ANY OF THAT
INFORMATION WHICH IS
UNDERSTANDABLE BUT WE WERE ABLE
TO GO OUTSIDE AND SING FOR HER.
MAKE SURE THAT SHE HAD A GOING
HOME SAW. AND PRAY FOR HER.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE DO AS
ADVOCATES. THAT'S NOT IN OUR
JOB DESCRIPTION BUT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE DO AS
TRADITIONAL PROTOCOLS. BUT IT'S
THOSE TYPES OF THINGS THAT WE
NEED TO BUILD RELATIONSHIPS
WITH OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
MAKING SURE THAT WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT AUTOPSIES THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO GET THE BILL THESE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE NETWORK. AND BE A
VOICE FOR THE SURVIVORS. THESE
PROTOCOLS ARE IMPORTANT. TO
HAVE IN PLACE. MOST IMPORTANTLY
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO DRESS THE HISTORICAL TRAUMA
THAT'S HAPPENED FOR A
CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE KNOW THAT
THROUGH THE GOLD RUSH. THEIR
HEADS ARE WOMEN WERE
TRAFFICKED. ARE YOUNG GIRLS ARE
TRAFFICKED. WE KNOW THAT THIS
IS THIS IS HAPPENED THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WITHIN EVEN THE
MISSION SYSTEM IN SAN FRANCISCO
I LIVE IN THE MISSION DISTRICT.
NOT FAR FROM ONE OF THOSE.
CHURCHES THAT WAS THERE AND I
KNOW THERE ARE RELATIVES THAT
ARE BURIED THERE. THIS WORK IS
VERY PERSONAL. JESSICA DIED IN
APRIL ON APRIL SIXTH TWENTY
NINETEEN THAT WAS MY BIRTHDAY.
FOUR MONTHS LATER I LOST MY
KNEES TO A DROWNING AND DON'T
MARK COUNTY DOWN OUR COUNTY HAS
ONE OF THE HIGHEST MMI W. CASES.
AND HER MURDER HER DEATH WAS.
IDENTIFIED AS A DROWNING WHICH
WE KNOW THAT WAS NOT TRUE. SO
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO WORK WITH OUR
NATIVE COMMUNITIES TO IDENTIFY
WAYS THAT WE CAN DO BETTER.
WHEN IT COMES TO IDENTIFYING
OUR MISSING AND MURDERED NATIVE
AMERICAN WOMEN. I JUST WANNA
SAY THANK YOU TO ALL OF YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE AND TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF OUR
SURVIVORS AND THE FAMILIES- I
JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU FOR
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU ARE
DOING- ON A LEGISLATIVE LEVEL
TO CREATE THIS CHANGE. SO I
THINK YOU ARE YOUNG. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
YOUR TESTIMONY. AND BRING IT TO
LIFE- THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE
EVEN DISCUSSING NOW WITH
MISSING AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS
WOMEN AND PERSONS I NEED
RESERVATIONS AND URBAN
COMMUNITIES- ISN'T SOMETHING
NEW. WHAT IS NEW IS BUILDING
THE ADVOCACY AMONGST THE
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE. A POSITION
AND ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF ALL
OF US IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- WE KNOW THAT THE
INDIAN PEOPLE HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS SUFFERED. I'M
GREAT AMOUNTS OF TRAUMA THROUGH
THE HIS HISTORY. ON THE LEAD TO
THE STATE'S STARTING WITH THE
SPANISH EXPLORATION TO THE GOLD
RUSH TO EVEN WHERE WE ARE
TODAY. TO TALK ABOUT THESE
ISSUES AND TREATMENT TOWARDS
NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN. IN
PARTICULAR HERE WITH- THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS. WE
KNOW THAT THEIR STERILIZATION
POLICIES TAKEN OUT UPON OUR
WOMEN. WE KNOW THAT DURING THE
FIRST SLAVES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE CALIFORNIA
INDIAN PEOPLE INCLUDING WOMEN
DURING THE MISSION PERIOD. AND
AN ONGOING THESE ARE ISSUES NOW
THAT HAVE. WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING IN INDIAN COUNTRY IN
INDIA COMMUNITIES THAT
KNOWLEDGE REYES AND RISE TO THE
LEVEL OF BUILDING THAT ADVOCACY
NO LONGER JUST. BOTTLED IN
INDIAN COUNTRY BUT NOW
EXPANDING INTO THE WOMAN'S
COPPICING GREEN GAINING ALLIES
ALONG THE TESTIMONY OF THE
HISTORICAL TRAUMA AND WHERE WE
GO FROM HERE. TO START TO HEAL
AND MOVE PEOPLE FORWARD. WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. BOB BARKER ASSEMBLY
POCKETBOOK- AT THIS TIME DO WE
HAVE THE JOY. DELLA ON THE-
CARE GO TO COST THIS. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE. CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES WONDERFUL- I APOLOGIZE
FOR MY TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES.
AUREL JAMES RAMOS CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA SELECT COMMITTEE ON
AMERICAN AFFAIRS AND MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY AND WOMEN'S
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS MY DEEP APPRECIATION
AND THANKS FOR INVITING ME TO
SPEAK BEFORE YOU TODAY ON SUCH
A CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
MIRJANA TOM DR JULIE PROFIT I
AM HUNGRY I'M ALSO KNOWN AS THE
PEOPLE OF THE WAX- AS WELL AS
AN OWNER TO SEND YOU. I'M A
PROFESSOR AND CHAIR OF AMERICAN
INDIAN STUDIES AT CAL STATE SAN
MARCOS AND THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIAN CULTURE AND
SOVEREIGNTY CENTER. WICKS ON
THE WALL OF THE CALIFORNIA IN
CULTURE AND SOVEREIGNTY CENTER.
IS A TREND THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA
USED TO SIGN THE VIOLENCE
AGAINST WOMEN ACT HE GIFTED
THAT CAN TO WANNA MODEL
DIXIELAND. FROM THE TIME
ABANDONED LISTEN YOU INDIANS.
ON ONE OF OUR FIERCEST
ADVOCATES. I'M IN SUPPORTING I
NEED WOMEN AND GIRLS IN THEIR
FIGHT FOR HEALTH AND WELLNESS
AND TO BE SAFE AND SHE GET THAT
THAT TO US. DISPLAY FOR OUR
STUDENTS AND GENERATIONS OF
CHANGE MAKERS TO WITNESS WHAT
THE POWER OF COLLECTIVE ACTION
CAN DO AND TO REMIND US THAT WE
MUST NEVER REMAIN IDLE. I WAS
RECENTLY APPOINTED TO SERVE AS
THE FIRST INDIGENOUS WOMEN ON
THE COMMISSION. ON THE STATUS
OF WOMEN AND GIRLS IN THAT
CAPACITY I WILL ADVOCATE FOR
NATIVE WOMEN AND GIRLS IN WORK
TIRES TIRES CLICK. TO SUPPORT
THEIR VISIBILITY SAFETY AROUND.
NATIVE WOMEN AND GIRLS HAVE
BEEN UNDER ASSAULT SINCE
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO. ALONG WITH
COLONIZATION CAME THE
KIDNAPPING RAPE AND MURDER OF
ANY OF THE GIRLS AND WOMEN. THE
LONG STANDING PROBLEM OF
VIOLENCE AGAINST NATIVE WOMEN
AND GIRLS IS NOT NEW AND IS NOT
A NEW PHENOMENON. THE VIOLENCE
AGAINST CALIFORNIA INDIAN WOMEN
AND GIRLS IS LONG DOCUMENTED BY
THE SPANISH MRS MISSION SYSTEM.
THE GOLD RUSH. AND THE STATE
SANCTIONED DEMOCRATIC DEATH
SQUADS. WERE PAID BOUNTIES FOR
MASS MURDERS AND ACTS OF
GENOCIDE. AS AN ACADEMIC. THIS
IS TYPICALLY WHERE I WOULD
PROVIDE YOU WITH STATS THAT
DIRECTLY RELATE TO MISSING AND
MURDERED INDIGENOUS WOMEN IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT IN FORT
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO NOT HAVE
THOSE. THIS UNDERSCORING THE
IMPORTANCE OF AB. THREE ZERO
NINE NINE. THE HIGH RATES OF
MISSING AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS
WOMEN CAN BE ATTRIBUTED TO A
VARIETY OF FACTORS. THE
SYSTEMATIC ERASURE AND
DEHUMANISATION OF NATIVE WOMEN
AND GIRLS. JURISDICTIONAL
ISSUES. DUE TO JURISDICTIONAL
ISSUES. AND JURISDICTIONAL
QUESTIONS IT MAY BE DIFFICULT
FOR THE FAMILY TO DETERMINE IF
THE TRIBE THE STATE ESPECIALLY
IN A PUBLIC A LOT TO A STATE
LIKE OURS WHERE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS PRIMARY
JURISDICTION FOR A MISSING.
WOMAN OR GIRL. THE LACK OF
COMMUNICATION AND PLANNING
AGENCY IS ALSO. ALBUM CHRONIC
UNDERFUNDING OF TRIBAL JUSTICE
SYSTEMS OR THE NEARBY SYSTEMS
INTENDED TO SUPPORT OUR WOMEN
GIRLS IS VERY MUCH AN ISSUE.
AND UNDER RESPONSIVENESS FROM
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS FAILURE OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO PRIORITIZE
MISSING AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS
WOMEN. WANTED DAHLE WOMEN
DISAPPEAR THERE IS OFTEN A
DELAYED OR NO RESPONSE FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT. MOST TIMES
INVESTIGATION IS STOPPED IF IT
IS KNOWN THAT A WOMAN WAS
UNKNOWN SUBSTANCE ABUSER. THESE
INVESTIGATIONS TEN DOES A SWEEP
UNDER THE RUG BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT. THESE WOMEN AND
GIRLS EVEN A WOMAN OUR YOUTH
WITH THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE ISSUE
IS SOMEONE'S DAUGHTER.
SOMEONE'S MOTHER SISTER COUSIN
DESERVES EQUAL ACCESS TO
JUSTICE NOT ONE CHILD EVER
WAKES UP AND SAYS HEY WHEN I
GROW UP I WANT TO BE A DRUG
ADDICT. WE KNOW FROM THE TWENTY
TEN TRIBAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMISSION REPORT OUR CHILDREN
ARE OFTEN THE FIRST RESPONDERS
TO AID THEIR MOTHERS AFTER
WITNESSING A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ALTERCATION. AND OUR NATIVE
CHILDREN'S. POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS RATE ARE TWICE AS HIGH
AS SOLDIERS COMING HOME FROM
AFGHANISTAN AND IRAQ. THE LACK
OF MEANINGFUL INVESTIGATIONS OF
A MOTHER WHO WAS MURDERED IN
CRITICAL. IS CRITICAL FOR THE
HEALING OF HER CHILDREN FAMILY
AND COMMUNITY LEFT BEHIND. THIS
IS VERY PERSONAL FOR ME AS A
CHILD TO HEROIN ADDICTS. MY
MOTHER WAS OFTEN VIEWED BY
SOCIETY AS A THROWAWAY PERSON.
SHE WAS MY MOTHER. AND I LOVE
JERRY MONTHLY I WOULD NOT BE
HERE IN FRONT OF YOU WITHOUT
HER. SO WHILE SHE'S NO LONGER
WITH US WE WORK TO MAKE SURE
THAT NO NATIVE WOMAN IS REDUCED
TO AN ABSTRACT. ERASED OR
TOSSED AWAY. IT SEX TRAFFICKERS
AND OTHER VIOLENT PREP
PREDATORS TARGET NEED WOMEN AND
GIRLS. THE LACK OF TRIBAL
NATIONS JURISDICTION OVER NON
INDIANS. HOLD WITHIN
KNOWLEDGEABLE SEX SEX
TRAFFICKERS OFTEN EXPLOIT THIS
AND THEY'RE LESS LIKELY TO BE
APPREHENDED AND PROSECUTE WE
MUST DO BETTER WE CAN DO BETTER
WE KNOW THAT THE ROOT OF
VIOLENCE AGAINST NATIVE WOMEN
AND GIRLS IS COLONIZATION THERE
IS AMPLE RESEARCH AND EVIDENCE
TO SUPPORT THAT STATEMENT.
GOING FORWARD WE MUST EMPOWER
CALIFORNIA TRIBES TO EMPOWER
THE FAMILIES OF THE MISSING AND
MURDERED TO RECEIVE THE JUSTICE
THAT IS OWED THEM BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY WE MUST LISTEN TO
TRIBAL NATIONS MANY OF WHO HAVE
OFFICE OF VIOLENCE AGAINST
WOMEN PROGRAMS LIKE THE LOYAL
BAND OF LISTING YOUR INDIANS
BIG VALLEY RANCHERIA PALM
ABANDONED LISTEN YOU INDIA
YUROK TRIBE AND TRIBAL
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS THE
STRONG HEARTED NEED WOMAN'S
COALITION. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MUST DO MORE THAN
MERELY PROVIDE THEM A SEAT AT
THE TABLE. THEY MAYES THEY MUST
TAKE DIRECTION FROM THEM AS
THEY ARE AND ARE ON THE
FRONTLINES OF ADDRESSING
MISSING AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS
WOMEN. TO NOT TAKE THIS ACTION
IS CONTRIBUTING TO THE MISSING
OR MURDERED INDIGENOUS WOMEN
RATES. THAT WE HAVE YET TO
COMPILE. I ENCOURAGE CENTERING
ENGAGEMENT WHICH TRIBAL NATIONS
AND THEIR PROGRAMS AND PEOPLE
DEDICATED TO ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE WE MUST PRIORITIZE NATIVE
WOMEN AND GIRLS AT EVERY
OPPORTUNITY. WE MUST
COLLECTIVELY WORK TOGETHER WITH
TRIBAL NATIONS LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ACADEMIA. POLICY MAKERS URBAN
AND RESERVATION SUPPORT SYSTEMS
TO ADDRESS MISSING AND MURDERED
INDIGENOUS WOMEN BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY FIND WAYS OF
PREVENTING MMI W. I WOULD LIKE
TO FINALLY UNDERSCORES SOME
IMPORTANT RECOMMENDATIONS.
THERE MUST BE AN EMPHASIS ON
MEANINGFUL GOVERNMENT TO
GOVERNMENT CONSULTATION WITH
ALL FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES.
YOU MUST CREATE AN INDIAN UNIT
WITHIN THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND OFFICE ON VIOLENCE
AGAINST WOMEN DEPARTMENT.
WITHIN AMERICAN INDIAN UNIT. WE
MUST DEVELOP GRANT PROGRAMS
WITH TRIBAL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND SEXUAL ASSAULT PROGRAMS IN
TRIBAL COALITIONS TO ADDRESS.
UNMET NEEDS SERVICING VICTIMS
OF VIOLENCE SUCH AS SUBSTANCE
ABUSE LIFE COACHING OCCASIONAL
TRAINING FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND EDUCATION. WE MUST DEVELOP
A COMMUNITY BASED RESEARCH TASK
FORCE IDENTIFYING GAPS AND
FAILURES IN ADDRESSING VIOLENCE
AGAINST NATIVE WOMEN WE MUST DO
THAT ALONG SIDE OF NATIVE. DATA
RESEARCHERS AND- SCHOLARS AND
COMMUNITY ACTIVISTS. AND AS AN
EDUCATOR IT WAS STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT WE MUST WAIVE
COLLEGE TUITION. FOR NATIVE
VICTIMS OF PHYSICAL AND SEXUAL
VIOLENCE REBUILD THEMSELVES
OFTEN VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT ARE
NOT THE MAIN BREADWINNERS AND
ARE OFTEN RETURN TO THEIR
ABUSERS IN FEAR GOING HOMELESS
OR NOT BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE
FOOD AND CLOTHING FOR THEIR
CHILDREN. WE NOW. WITH AN
EDUCATION AND FLEXIBLE
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES WOMEN
LEAVING ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIPS
WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES AND THEIR CHILDREN
MY PERSONAL MOTTO IS. EDUCATION
IS THE PATH TO SELF
DETERMINATION. WE NEED TO
DEVELOP MEANINGFUL ACCESSIBLE
SERVICES THAT PROMOTE HEALING
THEMSELVES TO THE STATE
ABILITY. I CAN PERSONALLY
ATTEST TO THE IMPACTS THESE
TYPES OF SERVICES AND PROGRAMS
HAVE. HAD THEY BEEN IN PLACE
WHEN I WAS A CHILD PERHAPS MY
MOTHER WOULD STILL BE HERE. I
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS FOR YOUR TIRELESS
COMMITMENT TO SERVICING OUR
NATIVE PEOPLE AND ESPECIALLY IN
CENTURY ARE AMERICAN INDIAN
WOMEN AND GIRLS IN THIS MOST
IMPORTANT AND PIVOTAL
LEGISLATION I PROMISE TO
DEDICATE MY TIME AND SERVICES
IN HONOR OF OUR NATIVE WOMEN
AND GIRLS AND HELP YOU IN ANY
CAPACITY THAT WE CAN. SO I
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK TODAY AND I'M HOPEFUL
THAT AB THREE ZERO NINE NINE IS
BUT THE FIRST STEP IN
ADDRESSING THAT MMI W. CRISIS
IN CALIFORNIA YOU SHALL LOVE
ACT MY HEART IS GOOD. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY-
PROFESSOR- OFTEN I WAS GONNA
SAY PROFESSOR DELLA TORY VERY
KNOWN EACH OTHER MANY YEARS AND
WORKING ON THESE THESE ISSUES
AND THE RECURRING MESSAGE THAT
WE HEAR IS THAT HEALING TAKES
PLACE FROM RIGHT IT ONCE WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE WRONGS OF THE
PAST AND IT STARTS BACK WITHIN
THE COLONIZATION PERIOD WITH
THE MISSION SYSTEM AND THEN
ULTIMATELY INTO THE GOLD RUSH
BUT IF WE'RE NOT WILLING TO.
ADMIT THOSE WRONGS THEN IN THAT
CONVERSATION PERIOD THAT AGAIN-
THE TREATMENT TOWARDS
CALIFORNIA DID WOMEN WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT SAVERY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IT STARTED WITH
THE CALIFORNIAN PEOPLE AND
PARTICULARLY THE WOMEN IN THE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE I
WANT TO THANK YOU A PROFESSOR
FOR BRINGING THOSE ISSUES
FORWARD- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. NEXT WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO SEE HEAR FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT- WITH US TODAY IS-
WILLIAM F. HAN SO HE'S A SHARER
OF HUMBOLDT COUNTY HE'S BEEN
THE SHERIFF OF HUMBOLDT COUNTY
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN HE
HAS ALSO SERVED AS AN
INVESTIGATOR AT THE HUMBOLDT
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE FROM 200-072-2000
THIRTEEN SHARE HAN SO IS A
BOARD MEMBER OF THE REDWOOD
TEEN CHALLENGE AND A MEMBER OF
THE ROTARY CLUB OF SOUTHWEST
EUREKA. HE WILL SPEAK ABOUT
HISTORICAL CHALLENGES FACING
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WHEN
IT COMES TO ENFORCING
CALIFORNIA CRIMINAL LAW IN
INDIAN COUNTRY AND THE BENEFITS
RESULTING FROM HIS TIME AS
SHERIFF IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY
USING CROSS DEPUTIES ATION
AGREEMENTS COLLABORATION AND
MUTUAL RESPECTFUL GOVERNMENT TO
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS HE IS
MAKING HIS PRESENTATION VIA
ZOOM. DO WE HAVE THE SHERIFF
WITH US. YES I AM HERE IN HERE
TERREL. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU.
OKAY I JUST WANT TO THANK-
CULTURE RAMOS AND I'M SURE
GARCIA FOR. ALLOWING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO THIS
PANEL IS A VERY VERY IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION- IT IS SOMETHING
THAT- WE NEED TO CONSIDER C.
WORK ON AND EVALUATES- AND- AND
I JUST ECHO THE SENTIMENTS OF
OR MY PREVIOUS SPEAKERS THAT
TRUST IS BUILT OVER TIME. AND
IT IS ALL ABOUT RELATIONSHIPS
IF WE WANT TO IMPROVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH- WITH
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT IT HAS
TO STAND NOW START FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING- AND WE HAVE TO
MAKE THAT CONSTANT EFFORT TO-
TO ALWAYS- MOVE FORWARD AND TO-
TO TRY AND MAKE SOME POSITIVE
CHANGES AND THAT'S WHAT I THINK
WE'VE DONE HERE COUPLE KIND
THAT'S WHAT I THINK. SURE SIR
DO WITHOUT THROUGHOUT THE STATE
BUT IT'S GOING TO GIVE YOU A
HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE- OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE ARE FACING
HERE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND-
AND FORCING TRONG- A LAWS ON
TRIBAL LAND AS YOU ARE- WELL
VERSED ON PUBLIC ONTO EIGHTY
BEING THAT CALIFORNIA I ONE OF
THE PUBLIC LAW TO EIGHTY STATES
THAT. AND CONGRESS PASSED IN
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE- PUBLIC
OUGHT. TO EIGHTY WHICH ENACTED.
ESSENTIALLY GAVE THIS CRIMINAL
JURY. ON TRIBE LAND. AND THIS
WAS ENACTED WITHOUT REAL ON
TRAVEL INTERACTION OR- WITHOUT
CONSULTING OR CONSENTING BY THE
TRIBES. AND SO CALIFORNIA IS
ONE OF THE FIRST ONES THAT-
THAT DID GO IN THIS DIRECTION
WHICH- WHICH GAVE ESSENTIALLY
THE SHERIFF'S. AUTHORITY TO
ENFORCE STATE LAW ON TRIBAL
LAND- NOW AS YOU KNOW TRIBE
STILL HAVE THE AUTHORITYOVER
CIVIL AND REGULATORY ISSUES ON
ON TRIBAL LAND AND MADE THE
TRIBES OF ESTABLISHED.
ORDINANCES AND TRIBAL COURTS AS
WELL AS TRIBAL POLICE
DEPARTMENT TO TRY AND CREATE
LONG ORDER. ON ON RESERVATIONS
AND RANCHERIAS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- BUT JURISDICTIONS STILL
COMES INTO QUESTION IS STILL
BEING DEBATED BY THE COURTS
TODAY- IN RECENT CASE LAW AS OF
A MONTH AGO THAT FEDERAL COURTS
JUST ESTABLISHED. YOU KNOW
THROUGH- COOLEY VERSUS UNITED
STATES. THAT TRIBAL POLICE DO
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO DETAIN
NON NATIVES ON TRIBAL LANDS-
WHEN IT IN DURING THE COURSE OF
AN INVESTIGATION THEY DETERMINE
THAT A STATE CRIME HAS. HAS
OCCURRED THEY CAN DETAIN AND
THEN TURN THAT SERVICE OVER TO
THE PROPER AUTHORITY BUT THEY
DO HAVE THAT RIGHT BUT IT'S
STILL BEING DEBATED- UP TO THAT
COURT DECISION THAT THEY DID
NOT HAVE THE RIGHT AND SO THEY
STOPPED AND DETAINED. SOMEONE
ON TRIBAL LANDS- AND THEY WORKS
NATIVE AMERICAN THEY HAD TO LET
HIM GO SO THOSE KIND OF THINGS
ARE CONTINUES TO BE DEBATED IN
COURTS- AND THROUGHOUT THE
STATE SO. ALSO JURISDICTION IS
ONE OF THOSE THINGS THAT'S
ALWAYS AN ISSUE ON TRIBAL LAND-
TRIBAL POLICE DEPARTMENTS HAVE
BEEN GROWING THROUGHOUT THE
STATE BECAUSE AS WE KNOW YOU
KNOW CRIME IS IT GET ANY BETTER
AND- SO TRYING TO RECOGNIZE THE
FACT THAT YOU KNOW THEY WANT TO
DO SOMETHING. OUT OF THE EIGHT
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN
HUMBLE COUNTY I HAVE- FOR
TRIBAL POLICE DEPARTMENTS
WITHIN WITH INJURED MY
JURISDICTION AND ONE- IS TRYING
TO GET ESTABLISHED RIGHT NOW SO
WE'RE GONNA HAVE ON THE NEXT
YEAR FIVE TROUBLED POLICE
DEPARTMENTS. OUT OF THE EIGHT.
BECAUSE PUBLIC SAFETY IS ONE OF
THE NUMBER ONE ISSUES ON TRIBAL
LAND- AND OUT OF THE AIDS I
THINK IT'S INTERESTING THAT
ONLY ONE HAS CLASS ACCESS
THAT'S THE CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SYSTEM THAT'S THE WAY THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN. COMMUNICATE
WITH EACH OTHER- AND TALKS
ABOUT MISSING PERSONS WANTED
PERSONS CRIMINAL HISTORY IN
THOSE KIND OF THINGS AND SO-
THAT'S THE ONE THING I WANT TO
BRING UP IN THE IN WILL DISCUSS
YOU KNOW HOW WE CAN. YOU KNOW
MOVE FORWARD BUT- JUST
INTERESTING THAT ONLY ONE OUT
OF EIGHT HAS THAT. SO AS AS AS-
ONE FORTIES OR STAB US IN
TROUBLE POLICE DEPARTMENTS YOU
KNOW MANY TROUBLED POLICE
DEPARTMENTS ARE HIRING.
CERTIFIED A POLICE OFFICER TO
ACTUALLY SAY. ARE CERTIFIED
RECRUITS TO TRAVEL OFFICERS
THAT HAVE GRADUATED THROUGH
POST CERTIFIED POLICE
ACADEMIES- AND THAT'S THE CASE
HERE IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY. AND
MANY OF THESE TRIBES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE ARE ACTUALLY GOING
AND GETTING DEPUTIES ATION
THROUGH THE BUREAU OF INDIAN
AFFAIRS AND THEY'RE GETTING
THEIR SPECIAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMISSION WHICH BASICALLY
GIVES THEM THE AUTHORITY TO- TO
DETAIN. AND TO INVESTIGATE
FEDERAL CERTAIN FEDERAL CRIMES
ON TRIBAL LAND. AND SO THAT'S
THE ABILITY FOR THEM TO BECOME
FEDERAL PEACE OFFICERS AND
TRAVEL OFFICERS. SO THEY CAN
ENFORCE ORDINANCES ON TRIBAL
LAND AS WELL AS CERTAIN FEDERAL
LAWS. AND THE PENAL CODE EIGHT
THIRTY POINT EIGHT. ACTUALLY
GIVES THE AUTHORITY FOR FEDERAL
OFFICERS TO DETAIN- ANYONE ON
TRIBAL LAND THAT. IS
POTENTIALLY VIOLATING A STATE
LAW. THEY WOULDN'T HAVE TO TURN
THAT DETENTION OVER TO THE
PROPER AUTHORITIES SO THEY GIVE
EXAMPLE THERE IS A VIOLATION OF
A TRIBAL WHAT ORDINANCE OR
FEDERAL LAW THEY DETAINED THE
SUBJECT THE SUBJECT HAS AN
ILLEGAL WEAPON ON THEM OR DRUGS
ON THEM. AT THAT POINT TIME AND
THEY'RE ABLE TO DETAIN THEM AND
THEN THEY CALL THE SHERIFF'S
OFFICE AND THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE
WILL RESPOND AND TAKE OVER THE
INVESTIGATION MUCH LIKE A
CITIZENS ARREST. SO MANY OF
THEM ARE UTILIZING THAT ASPECT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND IT IS
WORKING BUT- BUT I DO BELIEVE
THAT IT DOES FALL SHORT WITH
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THEY DO ALSO HAVE ASKED YOU
KNOW THEY CAN ISSUE CITATIONS
SO FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS THEY DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO MAKE ON YOUR REST SO
THEY CAN ARREST AND SIMPLY TAKE
SOMEONE TO JAIL FOR FEDERAL LAW
VIOLATION UNLESS THE TRIBE
ESTABLISHES A AB AND A CURSOR
RATIONS SYSTEM THEY DON'T HAVE
THAT ABILITY- SO THEY HAVE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO MAKE
AN ARREST ON ON SOME OF THOSE
ON SOME OF THOSE ISSUES- AND
SOME OF THE BIGGEST CRIMES THAT
WE KNOW THAT THAT THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH ON TRIBAL LAND ARE
ASSAULTS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE-
DRUGS ALCOHOL THREATS CASES AND
THOSE THE STATE KIND OF CRIMES
THAT THEY WOULD WE NEED HELP
WITH. AND AS WE LOOK AROUND THE
STATE WERE SEEN IN A VERY
DIFFICULT- STRUGGLE THAT MANY
OF OUR JURISDICTIONS ARE HAVING
WITH HIRING AND RETAINING LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALS IN
THIS JOB BECAUSE THE JOB IS
VERY DIFFICULT AND THE TASK IS
GETTING MORE DIFFICULT EVERY
DAY SO TRAVEL PLEASE ONCE THAT
ACCORDING AND WANTS TO- TO DO
MORE SO WE'VE DONE HERE IN
PUBLIC COUNTY SOME SOMEWHAT
UNIQUE AND IT'S GROWING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IS WE'VE
ESTABLISHED IMHO USE- WITH-
WITH THREE THE TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS BLUE LAKE LAVON AND
YUROK AND WHAT THAT IS THE
DEPUTIES ATION AGREEMENTS-
THROUGH A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING. WHAT I DO IS A
TRIBE EMPLOYS A TRIBAL
OFFICERS- AND ANYONE THAT'S
GONE THROUGH A CERTIFIED
BACKGROUND THEY WERE THEN ABLE
TO APPLY TO BECOME RESERVE
DEPUTY SHERIFF- THROUGH THE
HUMBOLDT COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE I SWEAR THE MINUTES
RESERVES I PUT A TRAVEL OFFICER
THROUGH A. SIXTEEN WEEK FIELD
TRAINING PROGRAM. AFTER THAT
THE TRAINING PER. THERE IS.
RESERVE SURE FOR THE SURE
OFFICE THEY WERE- AND ALSO IT.
ON THE U. THAT SORT. THEM AS A
DEPUTY SHERIFF AS WELL AS A
TRAVEL OFFICER SO.
THEORETICALLY A LOT OF A LOT OF
TROUBLES OR STEP THREE
JURISDICTIONS THAT THEY CAN
ACTUALLY ENFORCE TRIBAL LAW.
FEDERAL LAW AS WELL AS STATE
LAW. AT THAT POINT IN TIME THEY
BECOME A PART OF MY TEAM
THEY'RE ABLE TO DISPATCH RADIO
USED MY CLASS SYSTEM- INTERACTS
AND GET. ACCESS TO ALL THE-DATABASES NECESSARY TO. ENFORCE
STATE LAW IN TO INVESTIGATE LAW
ON TRIBAL LAND. IS BEEN
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN WIDELY
SUCCESSFUL AND YOU KNOW WE'RE
DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
TRY AND GET MORE. ON TRIBAL
OFFICERS THROUGH THIS PROGRAM
AND BE A PART OF OUR SYSTEM SO
THERE ARE RADIO IF THERE'S A
CALL ON TRIBAL LAND AND THERE'S
IT IS A TRIBAL OFFICER THAT'S A
DEPUTY SHERIFF. HE WILL GO TO
THAT FALL ALONG WITH ANOTHER
DEPUTY SHERIFF AND HE'LL WRITE
THE REPORTS TO THE
INVESTIGATION ON MY SYSTEMS AND
INSTEAD OF TO THE JUST RETURNS
OFFICE FOR PROSECUTION SO
AGAIN. HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I THINK
THAT WE ARE- VERY VERY MUCH
COMMITTED TO. AND IT'S SO
SUCCESSFUL EVEN THE OFFICE ARE
BECOME PART OF MY TRAINING. SO
FARM TRAINING DEFENSIVE TACTICS
THOSE KIND OF THINGS- TRAVEL
OFFICE OR PART OF MY STAFF AND-
AND THERE UTILIZED- TO TRAIN
OTHER DEPUTY SHERIFFS. SO AGAIN
TRUST IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
ALWAYS GOING TO CONTINUOUSLY
WORK ON I BELIEVE FACTS YOU
KNOW PART OF WHAT- THIRTY NINE
I SHOULD BE ADDRESSING IS HOW
WEBUILD TRUST IN THE
COMMUNITY. AND SO IT COMES DOWN
TO RELATIONSHIPS AND HOW DO WE
DO THIS BECAUSE WE NEED
WITNESSES ON TRIBAL LAND TO
COME FORWARD AND TELL US WHAT
THEY KNOW IN ORDER FOR US TO
FOLLOW UP. AND TO BE ABLE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN INVESTIGATING
CRIMES. SO SO I'VE COMMITTED TO
AGAIN REGULAR MEETINGS WITH OUR
TRAVEL LANCHED WORSENING
TRIBAL LEADERSHIP- GOVERNMENT
TO GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO HAVE
THAT AND I THINK THAT IS. ONE
OF THE KEYS TO SUCCESS AS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. ONE THE OTHER
KEYS TO SUCCESS IS ALLOWING
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS TO GAIN
CLASS ACCESS. NOW THE KARMIC
JUSTICE ESTABLISHED MANY YEARS
AGO THAT THE TRIBES DO HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO REQUEST ACCESS.
RIGHT NOW IT TAKES A LOT OF
PROCESS IN ORDER FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN. AND SO I YOU KNOW PART
OF THIRTY NINE NINE IS TO
REALLY I THINK YOU REALIZE HOW
WE CAN STREAMLINE THAT PROCESS
AND HOW WE CAN. GET TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS ON- YOU KNOW IN
THAT CLASS ACCESS AND THE
ABILITY FOR THEM TO. ENTER INTO
MISSING PERSONS. PROTECTIVE
ORDERS OF THOSE KIND OF THINGS
FROM THEIR COURT SYSTEM THAT
CAN ACTUALLY BE VERY VERY
BENEFICIAL- FOR ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT-
WE ALSO SHOULD BE ADDRESSING
IS. THE WAY IN SORT OF AN
ADDRESS HERE IS HOW WE
INVESTIGATE HOW WE DOCUMENTS-
MISSING MISSING PERSONS. RIGHT
NOW WE CHECK A BOX AS FAR AS-
WHAT THEY ARE YOU KNOW
PERCEIVED RACE IT IS AND- AND
RIGHT NOW. YOU KNOW WHY NOT
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO REQUEST
WHAT TRIBAL AFFILIATION AND A
HALF. BECAUSE LIKE I'M MISSING
A MISSING PERSON CASE WE ARE
MANDATED TAKE A MISSING PERSON
CASE NO MATTER WHERE THAT
PERSON WENT MISSING. AND THEN
WE PUSH THAT INVESTIGATION TO A
JURISDICTION WHERE THEY WERE
LAST SEEN. SO AS EXAMPLE IF
SOMEONE'S REPORTED MISSING IN
THE COUNTY BUT WE KNOW THAT
THEY WERE LAST SEEN IN
SACRAMENTO. I SAID SACRAMENTO
POLICE DEPARTMENT THAT'S
MISSING PERSONS REPORT WHY DID
WE DO THAT WITH TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT HAVE
ESTABLISHED POLICE DEPARTMENTS.
WHY COULD WE DO THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
DEFINITELY LOOK AT AND BE ABLE
TO FORWARD THAT INFORMATION TO.
THE TRIBAL GOVERNMENT SO THEY
HAVE AN IDEA OF THEIR TRIBAL
MEMBER THAT'S MISSING. AND THAT
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE A-
ADDRESS TO GET A PROCESS WITH
THIS- AS WELL AS- YOU KNOW.
TRAINING PUBLIC ONTO ANY
TRAINING OUR TRAINING ON
TROUBLE RESTRAINING ORDERS
TRIBAL LAW TRIBAL CULTURE IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ALL NEED MORE
ASSISTANCE WITH. IT IS
SOMETHING THAT- AS A PART OF-
THE CHAIR OF TRIBAL- THE TRAVEL
COULD BE SURE IF THE STATE
SERVICE ORGANIZATION WE ARE
COMMITTED. AND I CAN SPEAK ON
ALL OF THE TEACHERS WHEN WE ARE
COMMITTED TO TRY AND DO BETTER
AT THE CULTURAL AWARENESS
TRAINING AND TRY TO DO BETTER
AT LEARNING. YOU KNOW HOW TO
INTERACT BETTER WITH WITH OUR
TRAVEL COMMUNITIES GOVERNMENTS
GOVERNMENTS AND PEOPLE TO
PEOPLE. AND THAT'S GONNA BE
SOMETHING THAT'S GONNA BE VERY
VERY IMPORTANT TO ALL OF US.
AND AND WE ARE DEFINITELY
COMMITTED TO THIS AND SO AS WE
MOVE FORWARD I'M HERE FOR TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE BEEN- BEFORE BUT- BUT OUR
COMMITMENT IS TO WORK TOGETHER
OUR COMMITMENT IS TO. GET
BETTER AT SOLVING CRIMES. ONE
MISSING PERSON IS TOO MANY AND-
AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT WE DO EVERYTHING WE
POSSIBLY CAN TO INVESTIGATE.
AND TO DOCUMENT EVERY POSSIBLE
CASE SO WE CAN ACTUALLY SOLVE
THESE. FINE PEOPLE SOLVE
HOMICIDE INVESTIGATIONS AND DO
WE CAN TO BRING PEOPLE TO
JUSTICE AND- BRING TRUST. YOU
KNOW TO THE TROUBLE COMMITTEE
THAT WE ARE DOING EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO TRY AND STOP CRIME
AND BRING PEOPLE SOME CLOSURE
TO SOME. SERIOUS LONG CASES SO.
ANYWAY I'LL CONCLUDE WITH THAT
AGAIN I THINK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
ALL TODAY AND- LOOK. FORWARD TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE. THANK YOU O YOU SURE
HANS. FOR- BRINGING THIS UP
SPEED ON. A SOME SOLUTIONS THAT
ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED IN THE
AREA AS FAR AS CROSS
DEPOSITIONS MO YOU BUT ALSO
HIGHLIGHTING. THE COMPLEXITIES
THAT ARE THERE FEDERAL LAW
STATE LAW IN TRIBAL LAW. AND
LOOKING AT THE- CROSSED IF IT
IS AGES AND UTILIZING RESERVE
OFFICERS. THAT WOULD GO IN
THERE STARTS TO. SHOW THAT
THERE COULD BE A SOLUTION AT
LEAST FOR THE FEDERAL- AND THE
LOCAL COUNTY ASPECT OF IT
HOWEVER. WHAT'S HAPPENING THERE
IN YOUR JURISDICTION- PROBABLY
SHOULD BE EXPOSED TO THE REST
OF THE STATE OF HOW THEY
ACTUALLY IS WORKING. AND BUILT
ON MUTUAL RESPECT OF RESPECT
FROM THE TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS.
AND THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WORKING
TOGETHER ON SOMETHING THAT
TRULY IS WORKING ON IT THANK
YOU FOR THAT. AND OUR OFFICE
WILL CONTINUE TO BE ENGAGED IN
THIS TOPIC. AND WORKING WITH
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THE SAFETY OF ALL
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
OUR NEXT PRESENTER WILL BE A-
THE CHAIRWOMAN FROM HUBBLE
MOTEL POMO OF UPPER LAKE-
SHERRY TRIP UP- IS A VERY
RECOGNIZE INDIAN NATION LOCATED
IN UPPER LAKE CALIFORNIA
CHAIRWOMAN TRIP WAS ELECTED TO
THE TRIBES SEVEN MEMBER
EXECUTIVE COUNCIL AS VICE
CHAIRPERSON IN TWO THOUSAND
FOUR AND AS CHAIRPERSON- SHE
LEADS EFFORTS TO PRESERVE THE
TRIBE'S CULTURE SOVEREIGNTY.
AND ESTABLISH ECONOMIC SELF
RELIANCE CHAIRWOMAN TRIP I WILL
SPEAK TO THE KNOWN HISTORICAL
TENSIONS BETWEEN TRIBES AND
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT THE NEED
FOR MORE TRAINING AND EDUCATION
FOR ALL INVOLVED IN THIS ISSUE.
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT LOCAL AND
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS AND TRIBAL
CITIZENS CHAIRWOMAN TRIPLE ALSO
DISCUSSED HER TRIES BEST
PRACTICES AND COMMITMENT TO
BUILDING AND MAINTAINING MUTUAL
RESPECTFUL GOVERNMENT TO
GOVERNMENT RELATIONSHIPS AND
COLLABORATIVE TRAININGS AND
BEING GOOD NEIGHBORS ACROSS THE
WAY THAT GOES BOTH. BOTH WAYS
BEING GOOD NEIGHBORS ON THE
TRAVEL SITE AND GOOD NEIGHBORS
WITHIN THE COUNTY AND THE CITY
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE THERE
WELCOME THE HONORABLE A
CHAIRWOMAN SHERRY TRIPLE. GOOD
MORNING- AND THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE TODAY TO
TALK TO YOU ABOUT OUR
EXPERIENCES- AS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MENTIONED I AM THE CHAIR
WOMAN AND HAVE BEEN SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT. AND WAS THE
VICE CHAIR- SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND FOUR. WHEN OUR YOUNG
GOVERNMENT WAS JUST RE
ESTABLISHED. WE LIVE IN A VERY
RULE ON THAT BEAUTIFUL
COMMUNITY THAT IS REPRESENTED
BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN AG WE ARE
CURRY- IT IS ISOLATED- WITH
MOUNTAIN RANGES. OUR TRIBE HAS
RESIDED THERE SINCE TIME IN
MEMORIAL AND- YOU KNOW WE HAVE
HAD A DEEP AND RICH EXPERIENCE
IN THE COMMUNITY- BUT IT ALWAYS
WASN'T AS POSITIVE AS IT IS
TODAY- WE HAVE ALSO BEEN A
STRONG ADVOCATE. FOR
LEGISLATION LIKE THIS AND
OTHERS IN THE PAST-
PARTICULARLY AROUND TRAININGS-
OF RELATIVE TO TRIBES AND
RELATED ISSUES LIKE PL TWO
EIGHTY INDIAN CHILD WELFARE.
VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN AND
ARCHAEOLOGICAL CRIMES AS YOU
ALL ARE PROBABLY AWARE OF- AND
HAS BEEN MENTIONED EARLIER MUCH
OF THE LANDS IN CALIFORNIA WERE
A NATIVE LANDS AND- THROUGH THE
COURSE OF TIME- THROUGH
TERMINATION I'LL GIVE A LITTLE
BIT OF BACKGROUND ON OUR TRIBE
SPECIFICALLY. BUT THOSE PLANS
ARE NO LONGER WITHIN TRIBES
CONTROL AND THEREFORE- THE
EVIDENCE OF OUR EXISTENCE- IS
IN THE GROUND AND SO WHEN WE
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
CONTROL AND PRESERVE SOME OF
THOSE. ARTIFACTS IT BECOMES AN
ISSUE FOR TRIBES BECAUSE IT'S
CULTURALLY AND HISTORICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US- THAT THOSE
ITEMS REMAIN IN THE GROUND AND-
CALIFORNIA'S BEAUTIFUL THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF- A LOT OF
PROGRESS HERE BUT- OFTENTIMES
THAT ENDS UP BEING- IMPACTFUL
TO TRIBAL COMMUNITIES WHEN ARE.
THE EVIDENCE OF OUR EXISTENCE
IT IS EXPLOITED OR OR TAKEN.
TOM START TRIBE OF RESIDES IN
LAKE COUNTY CALIFORNIA IT IS A
BEAUTIFUL AREA VERY VERY SMALL
UNFORTUNATELY IT IS ALSO THE
POOREST COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA-
OUR TRIBE. WAS IMPACTED IN THE
EIGHTEEN FIFTIES BY A CALVARY
ACTION AGAINST OUR PEOPLE THAT-
MURDERED AND MASSACRED MANY OF
OUR WOMEN AND CHILDREN. THAT'S
THE BLOODY ISLAND MASSACRE. OUR
TRIBE WAS FIRST RECOGNIZED IN
THE EARLY NINETEEN HUNDREDS AND
EVENTUALLY AMASSED ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED SIX SIXTY ACRES-
HISTORICALLY THAT BECAME OUR
TRIBAL LANDS- UNFORTUNATELY IN
THE EIGHTEEN IN THE NINETEEN
FIFTIES. CONGRESS PASSED THE
CALIFORNIA RANCHERIA ACT WHICH
EFFECTIVELY TERMINATED ARE
FEDERAL RECOGNITION AND OUR
GOVERNMENT- AS A RESULT OF THE
ASSETS OF THE TRIBE AT THAT
TIME BEANLAND- IT WAS DIVVIED
UP AMONGST ARE RECOGNIZED
MEMBERS AND UNFORTUNATELY WHEN
LAND COMES OUT OF TRUSTED INTO
FEET SUBJECT TO TAXATION AND-
OUR- PEOPLE WERE HISTORICALLY
IMPOVERISHED AND COULD NOT
AFFORD THE TAXES STILL THE LAND
WAS LOST- IN. IN THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS WE ATTEMPTED TO
REESTABLISH OUR GOVERNMENT BUT
IN ORDER TO REGAIN OUR
RECOGNITION WE HAD TO SUE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY AND WE WANT OUR
LAWSUIT- AND THE LAWSUIT
BASICALLY SAID THAT ARE. THAT
WE HAD EXISTED AS A GOVERNMENT
AND WE WERE NEVER- NOT A
GOVERNMENT BUT UNFORTUNATELY
OUR LAND WAS LOST AT THAT TIME
SO OUR TRIBE WAS LANDLESS UP
UNTIL THE EARLY- TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHT. OUR BUT THE LAWSUIT
ALSO SAID THAT ARE- ARE. OUR
PERIMETER OF OUR TRUST LANDS
WAS NEVER DISTANCED APPLICANT
EVEN THOUGH WE DIDN'T ONET-
THAT STILL EXISTED IT BECOMES A
VERY COMPLEX SITUATION WHERE
AND ONE OR TWO OR FIVE MEMBERS
ON THE LITTLE PLOT OF LAND AND
IT IS IN TRUST BUT THE TRIBE AS
A GOVERNMENT DOES NOT HOLD
TRUST LANDS. IT'S VERY
COMPLICATED FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO UNDERSTAND WHERE
JURISDICTION OCCURS FOR THEM
AND WHERE IT DOESN'T- SO IT IT
BECAME A BIG ISSUE IN OUR
COMMUNITY THERE ARE SEVEN
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN
LAKE COUNTY SEVERAL OF THEM
WERE LANDLESS AS WELL- WE WERE
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO RE
ESTABLISH A SMALL. LAND BASED
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT AND
IT WAS FOR THE PURPOSES OF
GAMING IT WAS OUR EXPERIENCE IN
THAT PROCESS THAT REALLY WAS A-
A TESTIMONY TO HOW GOVERNMENTS
CAN REESTABLISH RELATIONSHIPS-
FORTUNATELY FOR US- WE WERE
ABLE TO OVERCOME SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES IN OUR IN OUR
COMMUNITY- BUT- AS A RESULT. OF
OUR LANDLESS NIS- AND THE LACK
OF POLICE FORCE AND AT THAT
TIME A VERY YOUNG GOVERNMENT
WHICH- WE BASICALLY HAD A
CONSTITUTION AND ROMAN
ORDINANCE IN AN ETHICS
ORDINANCE AND- AND NOT MUCH
MORE. WE RELIED SOLELY ON- THE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR- FOR
OUR PROTECTION- UNFORTUNATELY
ALSO BECAUSE OF OUR HISTORY OUR
PEOPLE AND MANY OF THE TRIBES
IN THE AREA. ARE DISTRUSTFUL OF
GOVERNMENT AND THAT INCLUDED
LAW ENFORCEMENT- TODAY HOWEVER.
WITH OUR MODERN GOVERNMENT WE-
AS A RESULT OF BEING LANDLESS
HAD TO GO THROUGH THE PROCESS
OF TRYING TO ACQUIRE TO PUT I
IN TRUST AND IN THAT TIME IT
WAS FOR A GAMING. OPPORTUNITY
BUT OUR- OUR SOUL- OUR SOLE
EFFORT WAS REALLY TO FOCUS ON
WORKING WITH THE COUNTY TO
MITIGATE THE IMPACTS OF THAT-
POTENTIAL CASINO IN THE
COMMUNITY- WE DID THAT THROUGH
NEGOTIATING- A GOVERNMENT TO
GOVERNMENT RELATIONSHIP. AN
MOU- IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE
SO IS VERY SOON AFTER OUR
GOVERNMENT WAS RE ESTABLISHED.
THAT PARLAYED INTO CONSIDERABLE
SUPPORT BY THE COMMUNITY WHEN
WE WERE GOING THROUGH THE TRUST
PROCESS TRYING TO PUT OUR LAND
INTO TRUST- UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE
ONLY ABLE TO REESTABLISH ELEVEN
ACRES. SO WE DON'T HAVE YOU
KNOW A LOT LARGE TRIBAL LAND
BASE ANYMORE- BUT IT WAS
THROUGH THOSE EFFORTS- WITH
WORKING WITH THE COUNTY- NOR
SURE FIRE PROTECTION DISTRICT
FOR EMERGENCY SERVICES.
ESTABLISHING AN MO YOU FOR FIRE
PROTECTION AND EMERGENCY
SERVICES AS WELL AS FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT. REALLY WAS AN EYE
OPENER FOR US AS TO THE RIGHT
WAY TO DO THINGS- I THINK IT
REALLY ESTABLISHED A GOOD
WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
LOCAL AUTHORITIES AND THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. AND THAT
HELPED US ALONG- YOU KNOW OVER
THE COURSE OF TIME.
UNFORTUNATELY EVEN THOUGH WE
MET PRETTY REGULARLY WITH
COUNTY OFFICIALS AND- AT NORTH
SHORE FIRE PROTECTION. THAT DID
NOT A IT WASN'T A PANACEA. I AM
FORTUNATELY IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN. WE EXPERIENCED AN
ISSUE OF STAGING IN WHAT WAS
DEEMED ARE- FOR PERCEIVED AS
BEING OUR TRIBE OUR TRIBAL
LANDS- THE LOCAL- EMERGENCY
SERVICES DID NOT REALIZE THAT.
THAT THOSE PLANS WERE NOT IN
TRUST. BUT IT RESULTED IN THE
STAGING INCIDENT WHERE.
EMERGENCY SERVICE RESPONDERS
WOULD NOT COME OUT TO WHAT THEY
DEEMED AS OUR RESERVATION
BECAUSE OF- A RECENT ISSUE THAT
THEY HAD HAD AN OR- IN A RECENT
CALL. BUT THEY LACKED CALL
CONTACT TO THE GOVERNMENT TO
INFORM US OF THE ISSUE. AND AS
A RESULT OF DELAY OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES BECAUSE THEY WANTED-
AND EXPORT TO COME ONTO OUR
LANDS- THEY A FAMILY MEMBER
PASSED AWAY. THAT AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE RESULTED AND A HUGE
UPROAR WITH OUR OUR OUR OUR
PEOPLE. AND A LOT OF CHALLENGES
FOR US AS A GOVERNMENT- BECAUSE
WE COULD NOT WE WERE SOLELY
RELIANT ON THOSE SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE. WE WERE ABLE TO- HAVE
SEVERAL MEETINGS WHICH RESULTED
AND THE- THE AGENCY. DEVELOPING
A STAGING POLICY THERE IS A
CALLING PROTOCOL IN PLACE NOW
BECAUSE- I'M THE FIRST ONE THEY
CALL IF THERE'S EVER AN ISSUE
THAT WOULD IMPACT THEIR
SERVICES OF OUR COMMUNITY- AND
THERE'S OTHERS YOU KNOW BEHIND
ME. BUT SINCE THEN WE'VE NEVER
HAD A STAGING ISSUE AT ALL. BUT
IT REMINDED US THAT EVEN WITH
THEM OF USE THAT WASN'T ENOUGH
WE HAD TO DO MORE AND
UNFORTUNATELY AGAIN WITH OUR
COMMUNITY BEING VERY POOR IT
WAS VERY DIFFICULT TO GET
RESOURCES TO PUT ON TRAININGS-
BUT AT. OUR TRIBE AFTER. A LOT
OF WORK AND EFFORT I HAVE A
BUSINESS THAT PROVIDES REVENUES
TO OUR TRIBE AND WE HAVE-
ESTABLISHED ON GOING- TRAININGS
IN THE COMMUNITY OF SUBJECT
MATTERS OF PL TWO EIGHTY
VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN INDIAN
CHILD WELFARE AND
ARCHAEOLOGICAL CRIMES- IT HAS
REALLY BEEN SUCCESSFUL FOR US
AND FORTUNATELY WITH OUR NEW
SHERIFF. HE HAS BEEN VERY VERY
MUCH. GATHER HAVE PUT ON THESE
TRAININGS FAIRLY REGULARLY WINS
IN FACT WE HAVE ANOTHER ONE
COMING UP- TOWARDS THE END OF
THIS YEAR. BUT IT WAS ALSO YOU
KNOW VERY MUCH- I'D AND AN
ISSUE- IT THAT ONE ONE TRAINING
IN A COMMUNITY ISN'T ENOUGH- I
WAS ASKED TO SIT ON A PANEL TO
HIRE THE NEW LIEUTENANT. IN THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND MARK
MY QUESTIONS TO THEM WERE ALL
AROUND PEEL TO EIGHTY ANDIT
WAS VERY CLEAR EVEN ONE OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT HAD GONE
THROUGH THE RECENT TRAINING.
DID NOT HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING.
THERE IS NEEDS TO BE CONSTANT
AND ONGOING INFORMATION AND
EDUCATION EARLY ON AND PRETTY
REGULARLY WITH TRIBES-
COMMUNITIES AND LAW ENFORCEMENT-
OUR TRIBE USE THE EXPERIENCE
THAT WE HAD GAINED THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF THE MO YOU AND
WORKING WITH THE COMMUNITY TWO
OF DEVELOP OTHER AMMO USE OF
SIGNIFICANCE- A. B. FIFTY TWO
WHICH PROVIDES TRIBES OF A
VOICE IN- IN CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS AND NOT A REQUIREMENT
FOR THE LOCAL AGENCIES. TO
CONSULT WITH TRIBES THAT
RESULTED IN CREATING AN AMMO AS
WITH OUR LOCAL AUTHORITY AND
I'M VERY THANKFUL FOR THAT WE
HAVE ONGOING TRAINING FOR
ARCHAEOLOGICAL CRIMES- WE WERE
ABLE TO. PROVIDE AN EDUCATIONAL
FILM ON THAT THAT I THINK CAN
REALLY ONE A LONG WAY BECAUSE
IT INVOLVED- THE SHARE OF IT
INVOLVES THE GOVERNOR THEN
GOVERNOR BROWN TRIBAL
LEADERSHIP ON WHAT IT MEANS TO
US WHEN BONDS OR ARTIFACTS ARE
FOUND ON OUR FORMER LANDS. AND
HOW WE CAN- RESOLVE TO
REPATRIATE THEM OR REBURIED
THEM SO WE HAVE ALSO DEVELOPED
AMMO USE WITH THE COUNTY IN
NORTH SHORE FIRE PROTECTION
DISTRICT ON EMERGENCY SERVICES
AROUND. ADDITIONAL BUILDINGS
AND LANDS THAT WE ACQUIRED-
NOTABLY- OUR TRIBE HAS ALSO
BEEN WORKING WITH. VARIOUS
ATTORNEYS GENERALS OF
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES
BECAUSE WE HAVE AN ONLINE
BUSINESS E. COMMERCE IS VITAL
TO OUR TRIBE BECAUSE OF OUR
LIMITED LAND BASE AND- YEAH
RULE LOCATION BUT WE HAVE
ENTERED INTO MEMORANDUMS OF
AGREEMENT WITH THE OF THE-
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF NEW MEXICO-
ONE OF THE VERY. POSITIVE
OUTCOMES OF BUILDING OUR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
OCCURRED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN AND I THINK THAT ALSO
HIGHLIGHTS WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY.
UNFORTUNATELY ONE OF OUR YOUNG
MOTHERS WOULDN'T WAS MURDERED
BY HER- BY HER SIGNIFICANT
OTHER AND THE FATHER OF THREE
OF HER. MINOR CHILDREN IN FRONT
OF THOSE. ABC THE SHERIFF
WHAT'S CALLED. TO RESPOND AND
THEY BASICALLY THEY WITNESSED
THE LIFE BEING BEATEN OUT OF
HER AND- FORTUNATELY- OF THE
SHERIFF KNEW US AND KNEW OUR
INDIAN CHILD WELFARE ADVOCATE
AND CONTACTED HER DIRECTLY SHE
WAS ABLE TO TAKE- CUSTODY OF
THOSE THREE CHILDREN SO THAT
THEY DID NOT GO INTO THE SYSTEM
WITHOUT- THE ONGOING
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING. WITH THE
COMMUNITY AND THE SHERIFF THOSE
CHILDREN PROBABLY WOULD HAVE
BEEN IN THE SYSTEM. INDIAN
CHILD WELFARE ISSUES VIOLENCE
AGAINST WOMEN ISSUES JUST THE
BASIC UNDERSTANDING OF PL TWO
EIGHTY IS VITAL TO TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES. I'M I'M I'M VERY
HAPPY THAT YOU HAVE TAKEN THIS
UP ASSEMBLY MEMBER- I'M
THANKFUL IT IS UNFORTUNATELY
TOO LATE FOR SOME OF OUR PEOPLE
BUT THE MORE EFFORTS TOWARDS
FINDING AND TRAININGS AND-
WORKING WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT I
THINK WILL DEFINITELY BE A
FACTOR. IN TURNING THE TIMES
AND THE CHANGE THAT WE NEED AS
TRIBAL PEOPLE AND TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY.
THANK YOU- CHAIRWOMAN. FOR
THAT- DESCRIPTION AND MANY
TIMES AND IN A COUNTRY YOU
BRING UP THE STAGE AND I MEAN I
REMEMBER THE RESERVATION WERE-
DEPUTIES THAT WOULD RESPOND
WITH PARKED ON THE STREET ND
TELL FIVE OR SIX UNITS COULD
SHOW UP AND THEN THEY COME IN
AND FORCE FOR SOMEONE THAT
MAYBE SLIPPED AND FELL- SOMEONE
THAT WAS MAYBE HAVING
ALTERCATION RIGHT THOSE THINGS
WHICH YOU BRING TO CENTER STAGE
THE REASON THAT WE'RE HERE. AND
THAT'S THE MISSING AND MURDERED
INDIGENOUS WOMEN THAT WE COULD
BE MORE PROACTIVE IN PRE VENT
THAT THEN THAT'S THAT'S WHERE
WE SHOULD BE HAD IT- THE
DESCRIPTION AND MY CONDOLENCES
FOR YOU AND YOUR PEOPLE FOR THE
SITUATION HAS HAPPENED. WHAT
HAPPENS TO THE YOUNG
INDIVIDUALS IS SEEING THAT.
THAT HAPPEN RIGHT THAT THAT
THAT ACTION WHERE'S THE
RESOURCES THE MENTAL RESOURCES
FOR THAT. AND AGAIN WE TALK
ABOUT HISTORIC TRAUMA. IS NOT
JUST HISTORIC IT'S STILL
HAPPENING NOW. BUT UNLESS WE'RE
WILLING TO GO BACK IN TIME IN
THE HISTORY DURING THE
COLONIZATION PERIOD AND MET.
THAT THAT HISTORIC TRAUMA
STARTED THERE. THEN WE'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO WORK FORWARD TO
START TO REALLY. MOVE FORWARD
ON TRUTH AND HEALING FOR ALL OF
OUR PEOPLE. THESE ARE THINGS
THAT THIS COMMITTEE IS
COMMITTED TO THE SELECT
COMMITTEE. AND THE NATIVE
AMERICAN LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
ONE ALSO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION- THE SPEAKER
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER WHENEVER
SPEAKERS TALKED ABOUT THE
WESTERN NEED FOR DATA- BUT IT'S
BEEN REPEATED MULTIPLE TIMES OF
HOW ONE ONE IS TOO MANY AND I
DO APPRECIATE. THE STORIES THAT
ARE BEING. I DO APPRECIATE THE
COURAGE TO RELIVE SOME OF THOSE
PROMISES HE SURE THE STORIES
WITH US AND HELP EDUCATE US-
REALLY IMPACTFUL AS WE TALK
ABOUT THE CONSTANT AND ONGOING
WORK WE HAVE TO DO. NEXT WE
HAVE MERRY LOVE THIS KEY FOR
WHO IS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF NATIVE AMERICAN
AFFAIRS AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. SHE'S
THE LIAISON BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA'S INDIA CITIZENS AND
THE DEPARTMENT. SHE HAS
PREVIOUSLY SERVED ON THE BOARD
OF TRUSTEES OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE ILLEGAL SERVICE SAYS THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN ADVISORY COUNCIL IN
THE NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION. THE BEST KEEPER
OPERATE AS ACCESS TO A PRIVATE
PRACTICE IN THOSE CHIEF LEGAL
COUNSEL FOR THE SAN LUIS REY
BAND OF MISSION INDIANS. MISS
LOPEZ KEEPER WILL DISCUSS HOW
AB THIRTY NINETY NINE SETS OUT
THE STATE STREET STRATEGY TO
ADDRESS MURDERED AND MISSING
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE SHOULD
SPEAK TO THAT TURNED TOURNEY
GENERAL BONDS COMMITMENT TO
IMPLEMENTING AB THIRTY NINETY
NINE INTO WORKING IN
COORDINATION CALIFORNIA'S
TRAVEL LOCAL AND FEDERAL
PARTNERS. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
EMILY I AM BOTTLE OF ALMELO
UNAI. HELLO EVERYONE GOOD
MORNING I THINK IT'S STILL
MORNING. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
KIND INTRODUCTION CHAIRWOMAN.
AS YOU SHARED MY NAME IS MARY
LOPEZ KIEFER AND I SERVE AS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
NATIVE AMERICAN AFFAIRS AT THE
OFFICE OF ATTORNEY GENERAL
BONTA- CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE- I WISH TO THANK YOU
BOTH- CHAIRMAN RAMOS AND
CHAIRWOMAN. GARCIA AND THE
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF YOUR
COMMITTEES- BOTH THE SELECT
COMMITTEE OF NATIVE AMERICAN
AFFAIRS AND THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS- IT
IS TRULY AN HONOR. ADD TO BE
INVITED BY BOTH OF YOUR ESTEEM
COMMITTEES TO DISCUSS ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY NINETY NINE. AT
TODAY I WILL SHARE WITH YOU THE
DOJ'S RESPONSIBILITIES IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB THIRTY
NINETY NINE AND ATTORNEY
GENERAL BONTA IS COMMITMENT TO
WORKING IN COLLABORATION AND
COORDINATION WITH OUR LOCAL
STATE TRIBAL AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PARTNERS AND
SURVIVORS AND FAMILIES IMPACTED
BY LOVED ONES WHO HAVE GONE
MISSING AND OR HAVE BEEN
VICTIMS OF HOMICIDE. I ALSO
WISH TO THANK MY FELLOW
PANELISTS TODAY FOR SHARING
BOTH THEIR PERSONAL. AND
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCES WITH
THE MISSING MURDERED INDIGENOUS
WOMEN MOVEMENT AS WELL AS THE
IMPACTS PUBLIC LAW TO EIGHTY. A
HAS HAD IN CALIFORNIA INDIAN
COUNTRY AND ITS NEIGHBORING
JURISDICTIONS. AS YOU HEARD
TODAY CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO ONE
OF THE LARGEST POPULATIONS OF
AMERICAN INDIAN ALASKAN NATIVE
PEOPLE. THE MOST RECENT TWENTY
TWENTY DATA OF FOR THE CENSUS
ESTIMATES THAT ONE MILLION FOUR
HUNDRED AND NINE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED AND NINE AMERICAN
INDIAN ALASKAN NATIVES. CALL
CALIFORNIA HOME I COUNTY FOR
APPROXIMATELY THREE POINT 6% OF
OUR STATE'S POPULATION. LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ACCORDING TO
TWENTY NINETEEN CENSUS DATA IS
HOME TO THE LARGEST SHARE
AMERICAN INDIAN ALASKAN NATIVES
IN CALIFORNIA WITH
APPROXIMATELY 21% LIVING WITHIN
THIS COUNTY. THE GENDER
DISTRIBUTION OF THE AMERICAN
INDIAN ALASKAN NATIVE
POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA IS
APPROXIMATELY EQUAL WITH BOTH
MEN AND WOMEN ACCOUNTING FOR
AROUND 50% OF THE POPULATION.
IN ADDITION CALIFORNIA IS HOME
TO APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SIX CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES
CONSISTING OF ONE HUNDRED AND
NINE FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
TRIBES AND SIXTY SEVEN NON
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN
A LITTLE OVER ONE HUNDRED
RESERVATIONS AND RANCHERIAS.
THAT NEIGHBOR THIRTY FOUR OF
OUR FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
EIGHTY THIRTY NINETY NINE
CREATED THE NEW TRAVEL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OFFICE OF
NATIVE AMERICAN AFFAIRS. AB
THIRTY NINETY NINE HAS TWO
MAJOR COMPONENTS THE FIRST
COMPONENT ADDRESSES THE
COMPLEXITIES THAT REMAINING
CALIFORNIA INDIAN COUNTRY.
REGARDING THE INCONSISTENT
IMPLEMENTATION APPEAL TO EIGHTY
IT REQUIRES THE DOJ TO PROVIDE
TRAINING AND GUIDANCE TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. AND
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS TO HELP
REDUCE UNCERTAINTY REGARDING
CRIMINAL JURISDICTION AND
IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY ON TRIBAL
LANDS. THE SECOND COMPONENT OF
AB THIRTY NINE NINE THE SUBJECT
OF THIS HEARING. CALLS FOR THE
DOJ TO STUDY CHALLENGES RELATED
TO THE REPORTING AND
IDENTIFICATION OF MISSING AND
MURDERED NATIVE AMERICANS IN
CALIFORNIA. PARTICULARLY WOMEN
AND GIRLS. THIS COMPONENT WILL
REQUIRE THE DOJ TO PREPARE A
REPORT OF RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE LEGISLATURE ON HOW TO
ADDRESS THE POTENTIAL BARRIERS
THAT MAY BE CONTRIBUTING TO THE
LACK OF REPORTING AND
IDENTIFICATION AND MISSING AND
MURDERED NATIVE AMERICANS IN
CALIFORNIA. WELL THESE TWO
SEPARATE WELL THESE ARE TWO
SEPARATE COMPONENTS WITHIN THE
LAW THERE ARE VERY MUCH
INTERRELATED AS YOU'VE HEARD
TODAY. IMPLEMENTATION OF AB
THIRTY NINE NINE WILL HAVE
INPUT INTO IMPACT ON PUBLIC
SAFETY CONCERNS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
POPULATION. WELL IT IS ACCURATE
THAT THE FIRST COMPONENT OF THE
LAW ONLY IMPACTS THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES THAT
HAVE RESERVATIONS OR RANCHERIAS
AND THE THIRTY FOUR COUNTIES
THAT NEIGHBOR THOSE
RESERVATIONS OR RANCHERIAS THE
SECOND COMPONENT RELATING TO
CALIFORNIA'S MISSING AND
MURDERED NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE
R. MM N. A. P. CALLS FOR A
STATEWIDE STUDY THAT IS
INCLUSIVE OF ALL AREAS IN WHICH
ALL NATIVE AMERICANS LIVE. IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I SHARED WITH
YOU BY MY FELLOW PANELISTS. IN
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE. YOU THE
US CONGRESS ENACTED PL TWO
EIGHTY. EXPRESSLY TRANSFERRING
FEDERAL CRIMINAL JURISDICTION
OVER MOST CRIMES COMMITTED BY
OR AGAINST NATIVE AMERICANS ON
INDIAN LAND FOR THE FEDERAL
JURISDICTION. I MEAN FOR HIS
NAME FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO FIVE AND THEN
LATER SIX STATES. THESE STATES
WERE KNOWN AS THE MANDATORY PL
TWO EIGHTY STATES. AND THE
STATES COULD NOT REFUSE
JURISDICTION. PL TWO EIGHTY
PROVIDED NO FINANCIAL SUPPORT
FOR THE NEWLY ESTABLISHED STATE
LAW ENFORCEMENT
RESPONSIBILITIES. NOR DID THE
LAW REQUIRE CONSENT OF THE
AFFECTED TRIBES. IT IS ALSO
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT PO TWO
EIGHTY DID NOT ELIMINATE OR
LIMIT CROP TRIBAL CRIMINAL
JURISDICTION AND THEREFORE THE
TRIBES AND THE STATE SHARE
CONCURRENT CRIMINAL
JURISDICTION IN INDIAN COUNTRY.
AS SUCH THE TRIBES MAY EXERCISE
THEIR TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY BY
ESTABLISHING TRIBAL COURTS AND
TRIBAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE SIX
MANDATORY APPEAL TO EIGHTY
STATES AND ALTHOUGH PL TWO
EIGHTY HAS BEEN IN EXISTENCE
FOR ALMOST SEVENTY YEARS. IT'S
REQUIREMENTS AND IMPLICATIONS
OFTEN REMAIN CONFUSING AMONG
STATE. LOCAL AND TRIBAL
AUTHORITIES GENERALLY PEEL TO
EIGHTIES COMPLEXITIES CAN AND
HAS LED TO PUBLIC SAFETY
UNCERTAINTY AND FRUSTRATION
AMONG TRIBAL COMMUNITIES AND
THEIR NEIGHBORS. THIS
UNCERTAINTY AND FRUSTRATION HAS
UNFORTUNATELY RESULTED IN PEEL
TO EIGHTY BEING APPLIED
INCONSISTENTLY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND AS CHAIRMAN RAMOS
EXPRESSED EARLIER HISTORICAL
AND CULTURAL ISSUES HEAVILY
IMPACT BUT CAUSES RESULTS AND
RESOLUTION OF VIOLENCE ON
TRIBAL LANDS. THE HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA'S TREATMENT OF ITS
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE IS AS
GOVERNOR NEWSOM EXPRESSED IN
TWENTY NINETEEN ONE OF GENOCIDE.
FILLED WITH UNSPEAKABLE TRAUMA
FROM STATE AND FEDERAL POLICIES
AND LAWS. THAT HAVE LONG
LASTING EFFECT ON ITS NATIVE
AMERICAN POPULATION FROM THE
NORTH TO THE SOUTH AND
EVERYWHERE IN BETWEEN. THE
STATE'S INVOLVEMENT IN THE
EIGHTEEN AND RATIFY TREATIES
IT'S LAWS ALLOWING CHILDREN TO
BE TAKEN FORCEFULLY FROM THEIR
FAMILIES INSTITUTING INDENTURED
SERVITUDE FOR NATIVE AMERICANS
OF ALL AGES AND GENDERS AND ITS
ROLE IN INDIAN BOARDING SCHOOLS
ARE JUST SOME OF THE FACTORS.
THAT ARE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICANS HAVE SUFFERED THROUGH.
THROUGH VARIOUS STUDIES AND
LITERATURE IT IS CLEAR THAT THE
EFFECT OF THIS HISTORICAL
TRAUMA IS STILL VERY MUCH
PRESENT TODAY IN HOW ARE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
POPULATION EXPERIENCES VIOLENCE
AND THEIR INTERACTIONS WITH
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES. WHETHER IT
BE THROUGH OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM OUR SOCIAL SERVICES
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. AB THIRTY
NINETY NINE IS BUT A FIRST STEP
IN ADDRESSING CONCERNS
SURROUNDINGMISSING AND
MURDERED NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA. AND IT
REPRESENTS CALIFORNIA'S
STRATEGY IN ADDRESSING AND
AMEND THE P. AB THIRTY NINETY
NINE SPECIFICALLY CALLS UPON
THE DOJ TO ALSO CONDUCT A STUDY
TO DETERMINE HOW TO INCREASE
STATE CRIMINAL JURISDICTION
PROTECTIVE AND INVESTIGATIVE
RESOURCES FOR REPORTING AND
IDENTIFYING MISSING AND OR
MURDERED NATIVE AMERICANS IN
CALIFORNIA. THE STUDY MUST
INCLUDE ALL OF THE FOLLOWING. A
DETERMINATION OF THE SCOPE OF
THE ISSUE OF MISSING AND ARE
MURDERED NATIVE AMERICANS IN
CALIFORNIA. IDENTIFICATION OF
BARRIERS IN REPORTING OR
INVESTIGATING MISSING AND OR
MURDERED NATIVE AMERICANS IN
CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY WOMEN
AND GIRLS. AND LASTLY WAYS TO
CREATE PARTNERSHIPS TO INCREASE
CROSS REPORTING AND
INVESTIGATION OF MISSING AND
ARE MURDERED NATIVE AMERICANS
IN CALIFORNIA BETWEEN FEDERAL
STATE. LOCAL AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS INCLUDING TRAVEL
GOVERNMENTS WITHOUT TRIBAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. AS PART
OF THE STUDY THE DEPARTMENT IS
TO CONDUCT OUTREACH TO
CALIFORNIA TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO THAT'S
INCLUDING OUR URBAN COMMUNITIES
AND OUR- ALSO THE COMMUNITIES
WITHIN TRIBAL LANDS AND LOCAL
AND STATE FEDERAL CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AGENCIES. INCLUDING BUT
NOT LIMITED TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND COURTS. AND LASTLY
THE DOJ IS REQUIRED TO SUBMIT A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE THAT
SHALL INCLUDE. DATA AND
ANALYSIS OF THE NUMBER OF
MISSING AND MURDERED NATIVE
AMERICANS IN CALIFORNIA.
IDENTIFICATION OF THE BARRIERS
TO PROVIDING STATE RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS M. M. AN A. P. AND
RECOMMEND RECOMMENDATIONS
INCLUDING ANY PROPOSED
LEGISLATION TO IMPROVE THE
REPORTING AND IDENTIFICATION A
MISSING AND ARE MURDERED NATIVE
AMERICANS IN CALIFORNIA. I
SHARED WITH US BY CHAIRMAN
GARCIA THE DOJ WILL RECEIVE
FUNDING FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF AB THIRTY NINETY NINE FOR
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS COMMENCING
NEXT MONTH. THANK YOU. THIS
FUNDING WILL PROVIDE THE DOJ
WITH THE NECESSARY RESOURCES TO
IMPLEMENT THE TWO COMPONENTS OF
AB THIRTY NINETY NINE. IN
PREPARATION FOR THE MNA P.
COMPONENT OF THE LAW THE OFFICE
OF NATIVE AMERICAN AFFAIRS
UNDER THE DIRECTION OF ATTORNEY
GENERAL ROB BONTA HAS BEGUN TO
ENGAGE WITH OTHER ENTITIES.
CONDUCTING SIMILAR STUDIES AND
REPORTS ON MISSING AND MURDERED
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE. EITHER
OFTEN REFERENCED AS MISSING
MURDERED INDIGENOUS PEOPLE
MISSING AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS
WOMEN MISSING MURDERED
INDIGENOUS WOMEN AND GIRLS BUT
FOR CALIFORNIA OUR LAW STATES
THAT IT'S MISSING MURDERED
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE. FOR
INSTANCE ON A NATIONAL LEVEL.
OPERATION LADY JUSTICE WHICH
WAS ESTABLISHED BY PRESIDENTIAL
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF MISSING AND MURDERED
INDIGENOUS WOMEN LATER TO BE
RENAMED INDIGENOUS PEOPLE. HAS
DONE- AND CONTINUES TO DO
SIGNIFICANT RESEARCH THAT
ASSIST LOCAL STATE AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS AS WELL AS M. M. I.
P. ORGANIZATIONS. MOREOVER TEN
OTHER STATES HAVE BEGUN TO
ADDRESS THE CRISIS WITHIN THEIR
BORDERS. OF THOSE TEN STATES
FOR WERE MIGHT MANDATORY PL TWO
EIGHTY STATES LIKE CALIFORNIA.
A MAJORITY OF THESE REPORTS
HAVE FOUND THAT NATIVE
AMERICANS MAKE UP A
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF BOTH
MISSING PERSONS AND VICTIMS OF
HOMICIDE. FOR INSTANCE IN
MINNESOTA A MANDATORY PL TWO
EIGHTY STATE. IT FOUND THAT
AMERICAN INDIANS MADE UP 2% OF
THEIR STATE'S POPULATION AND
AMERICAN INDIAN WOMEN AND GIRLS
COMPRISED 1% YET IN ANY GIVEN
MONTH AMERICAN INDIAN WOMEN AND
GIRLS MADE UP 15% OF THE
FEMALES MISSING CASES. AN 8% OF
ALL FEMALE HOMICIDES. HOWEVER
EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE GAINED
SIGNIFICANT INSIGHT AS TO WHAT
IS OCCURRING IN OTHER STATES
AND WHAT IS HAPPENING ON A
NATIONAL LEVEL. OUR FEDERAL
COUNTERPARTS AT OPERATION LADY
JUSTICE CAUTION THAT EVEN
THOUGH MMI PETE IS A NATIONAL
CRISIS THE RESEARCH DOES NOT
INDICATE THAT EVERY STATE OR
EVERY TRY WILL BE IMPACTED IN
THE SAME WAY. OR AT ALL. NINE
OF THE TEN STATES THAT HAVE
ISSUED THEIR FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BURIED IN
THEIR REPORTING. HOWEVER THE
REPORTS EACH IDENTIFIED
NUMEROUS SYSTEMIC BARRIERSTO
TRACKING VIOLENCE AGAINST
INDIGENOUS WOMEN AND GIRLS.
THESE BARRIERS INCLUDE RACIAL
MIS CLASSIFICATION JUDICIAL I'M
SIDNEY JURISDICTIONAL ISSUES
AND SIGNIFICANT DISTRUST OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT SOMETHING YOU'VE
HEARD OVER AND OVER TODAY. THE
RECOMMENDATIONS MOST COMMONLY
IDENTIFIED WHERE THE FOLLOWING.
ONE TO INCREASE AWARENESS AND
EDUCATION A MISSING MURDERED
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE TO IMPROVE
AND INCREASE DATA COLLECTION
EFFORTS AND ACCESS TO THE DATA
SYSTEMS BY NON. GOVERNMENTAL
ENTITIES TO IMPROVE AND
INCREASE LAW ENFORCEMENT
TRAININGS ON INTERACTING WITH
TRIBAL PEOPLE AND REPORTING
PROTOCOLS AND LASTLY TO IMPROVE
LAW ENFORCEMENT RELATIONSHIPS
AND ENGAGEMENT WITH TRIBES.
THERE ARE IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THE FINDINGS WERE
MADE ACROSS THE BOARD REGARDING
THE INADEQUACIES OF THE MISSING
PERSONS DATABASES BOTH STATE
AND NATIONWIDE AT THE HIGHER
LEVELS OF RACIAL THIS
CLASSIFICATION. LACK A TRIBAL
AFFILIATION OR TRIBAL
CITIZENSHIP INFORMATION AND THE
SITUATION OF UNDER REPORTING.
THE DOJ HAS ALSO BEGUN TO MEET
INFORMALLY WITH TRIBAL LEADERS
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
REPRESENTATIVES TRAVEL
ADVOCATES AND OTHERS TO ASSIST
US IN HOW WE SHOULD BEST
APPROACH AB THIRTY NINETY NINES
IMPLEMENTATION. MOVING FORWARD
THE OFFICE OF NATIVE AMERICAN
AFFAIRS IN COORDINATION WITH
THE DOJ'S RESEARCH CENTER AND
DIVISION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
WILL BE ENGAGING IN LISTENING
SESSIONS TO DISCUSS MMN A P.
AND WILL BE INCLUSIVE TO ALL
PERSPECTIVES ON THE ISSUES
PRESENTED. THESE LISTENING
SESSIONS WILL BE HELD STATE
WIDE BOTH VIRTUALLY AND IN
PERSON WHERE APPROPRIATE. AND
TRIBAL AND WE WOULD ALSO- LIKE
TO SHARE THAT WE HAVE LEARNED
SO MUCH FROM OUR FEDERAL STATE
LOCAL AND TRIBAL COUNTERPARTS
AND OUR TRIBAL ADVOCACY
PARTNERS. MORE OVER WE ARE
CONFIDENT THAT ARE INCLUSIVE
EFFORTS. IN ASSESSING THE SCOPE
OF THE CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA AND
DOJ'S COMMITMENT TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY AND IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH ALL INTERESTED
INDIVIDUALS AND BODIES THAT AB
THIRTY NINETY NINE WILL BE
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED. THE
WORK AHEAD WILL NOT BE EASY BUT
ATTORNEY GENERAL BONTA AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OUR
DEDICATED TO ADDRESSING THE
CHALLENGES IDENTIFIED IN AB
THIRTY NINETY NINE. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR INVITING ME TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS MORNING'S
HEARING AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY THANK YOU FOR
THE WORK ABILITY WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE TO-
COMPLY WITH AB THIRTY NINETY
NINE. I'M NOW WITH THE FUNDING
THAT'S GOING TO- THE DEPARTMENT
OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL. WE
ANTICIPATE SEVERAL- SELECT
COMMITTEE HEARING SAYS GETTING
UPDATES AS TO WHERE WE'RE AT
WITHIN THE PROCESS OF THE
ONGOING. BILL IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIRTY NINETY NINE I WANT TO
ALSO HIGHLIGHT THAT- MISTER
LOPEZ KEEPER. AS ALSO A FORMER
PROSECUTOR WITHIN THE SAN
FRANCISCO DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE THERE SO JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE HIGHLIGHTED THAT. IT'S
THERE WE GOT A LOT OF WORK TO
DO WE DID SAY THAT THIS WASN'T
THE END OF IT THIS WAS THE
BEGINNING OF ALL THE WORK THAT
WE NEED TO DO. FOR MAKE UP FOR
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY YEARS OF
THE VOICES BEEN ABSENT AND A
LOT OF THESE- AREAS YOU HEARD
IT HERE TODAY. WITH THE
TESTIMONY- WITH ALL THOSE
PRISONERS THAT ARE THERE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU FOR YOUR
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IF THERE'S
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT THAT WE
WOULD HAVE AT THIS TIME. ABOUT
ANYONE ON THE PHONES. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT TEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU AND INTO THE
LEGISLATORS IN THE MEMBERS ARE
HERE WITH US FROM WITHIN THE
WOMAN'S POCKETS AND- SELECT
COMMITTEE AND THE NATIVE
AMERICAN LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I
ME HEARING THE TESTIMONY OF
ISSUES. THAT ON THIS BODY
HASN'T BEEN ENGAGED IN WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIRTY NINETY
NINE. AND HE HEARD A LOT OF THE
TESTIMONY MOVING FORWARD. AT
THIS TIME WE WANT TO OPEN UP
FOR LEGISLATORS THEY HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON- YES I WANT TO
THANK BOTH CHAIRS FOR. PUTTING
THIS ON VERY INFORMATIVE- ONE
OF THE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS I
DO HAVE FOR A FUTURE
DISCUSSION. WOULD BE. FROM THE
SHARE FROM HOPE HUMBOLDT WHO
SPOKE ABOUT THE COMMUNICATIONS-
SITUATION WHERE THEIR OWN
COMMUNICATIONS CAN COMMUNICATE
WITH OTHERS BUT MOST IS. BUT
MOST OF. THE OTHER TRIBES DO
NOT HAVE THESE COMMUNICATIONS
THIS IS NOT ONLY INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AS WE KNOW WHEN
ANYBODY WHO GOES MISSING
GETTING THAT INTO A SYSTEM THAT
GOES THROUGHOUT THE STATE IS
OUR BEST CHANCE OF NOT ONLY
FINDING. THE MISSING CHILDREN-
BUT THE TAKE YOUR AWAY ON THIS
TOPIC- MISSING NATIVE AMERICAN
WOMEN SO US LOOKING AT THOSE
COMMUNICATIONS SYSTEMS AND HOW
TO GET ACCESS FOR OTHER TRIBES
I THINK WOULD BE VERY VERY
IMPORTANT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS-
MADAM MAJORITY LEADER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR BUT I WANT TO
SAY MY HEART IS FULL I KNOW
THAT WITH OUR YOUNG LEADERS AND
WITH THE OTHER LEADERS THE
ADVOCATES THIS IS NOT GOING TO
BE THIS IS GOING TO GO AWAY. IT
REALLY MAKES A DIFFERENCE WHO'S
AT THE TABLE AND HAVING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JAMES RAMOS
HERE AT THE STATE ASSEMBLY.
HAVING HIM CONVENE AND NATIVE
AMERICAN CAUCUS FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN THE HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA AND NOW HAVING THE
SELECT COMMITTEE IT MAKES A
DIFFERENCE HAVING YOU ALL HERE
TODAY MADE A DIFFERENCE AND I
WANTED TO KNOW THAT WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED. TO MAKING
SURE THE IT IS WAS A DRESS THAT
WE FOLLOW IN THE LEAD OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS IN
ADDRESSING THIS. AND FOR OUR
YOUNG WOMAN FROM FROM THE SOME
OF THE TRIBE I WANT TO TELL YOU
HOW VERY PROUD I AM OF YOUR
CONTINUED WORK IN THIS IN THIS
FIELD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AMOUNT OF
MAJORITY LEADER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IT WE TALKED ABOUT THE VIOLENCE
THAT NATIVE AMERICAN.
EXPERIENCE AT A VERY HIGH
LEVEL. IF YOU SEE IT IN
CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS
NOT CONSIDERED A VIOLENT CRIME.
THE CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE.
CHAMPIONING A CHILD FOR SEX. IS
NOT CONSIDERED A LOT OF CRIME
OR THE PEOPLE OF. HATE CRIMES
WHICH WE ALL KNOW TOO WELL. IS
NOT CONSIDERED A LOT OF CRIME
IN THE CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE
WHICH IS NONSENSICAL IN MY
OPINION OBVIOUSLY IF YOU COMMIT
THESE CRIMES. ELIGIBLE FOR
EARLY RELEASE. UPON THE
TOUGHEST THING THEY SHOULD HAVE
TALKED ABOUT FOLKS TALKED ABOUT
WERE MISSING PERSONS. AND IT'S-
MISSING PERSON CASES ARE TOUGH
NUMBER ONE. BECAUSE IN THE VAST
MAJORITY CASES. LAW ENFORCEMENT
WILL NOT GO OUT THERE TO LOOK
FOR THAT PERSON. A LESSER RISK
OR MAYBE UNDER THE AGE OF
TWELVE. BUT THEY RECEIVE SO
MANY MISSING PERSON CASES. AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT SO INUNDATED.
OTHER THE INTERNET GETTING
INFORMATION AND- FUND THE
REPORTING ENDING INTO A
NATIONWIDE SYSTEM. THAT'S
PRETTY MUCH IT BECAUSE YOU
DON'T INVESTIGATE MISSING
PERSON CASES SO IT'S TOUGH
FULLER SOME OF THE PIE THE
TOUGHEST CASES. AND GOES SITE
WHICH ONES THAT THAT WARRANT-
FOLLOW UP ON THAT AND WHICH
DON'T AND THEN THE MAJORITY
DON'T FOR THE MOST EVERYBODY.
THIS WILL SIMPLE THINGS YOU
TAKE MISSING PERSON CASES EVERY
DAY AND THIS IS A LITTLE BIT
THE NEW LAST LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT BUT- MOST THE FOLKS.
ARE MISSING- END UP COMING BACK
NOT ALL CASES BUT THAT'S THAT'S
THAT'S THE REALITY THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT FACES AND- IF YOU
PUT OUT MISSING PERSONS EVERY
DAY ON TV OR PUT OUT PRESS
RELEASES- PRISON IT BECOMES
WHITE NOISE THEY DREADED
DEFINITELY BALANCE AND THERE'S-
THERE'S A WAY TO DO THAT- BUT
YOU KNOW WE DO THIS THIS IS A
START- I WANT TO THANK BOTH
CHAIRS FOR IT FOR COMPLETING
THIS- INFORMATIONAL HEARING- GO
START SOMEWHERE. SO IT'S GOOD
TO HEAR THE DISCUSSION ONE
THINK OF SPEAKERS ARE VERY
INFORMATIVE I LEARNT A LOT
TODAY AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN
TEAMS DISCUSSION AND HOW WE.
CAN RESOLVE THESE ISSUES THANK
YOU ALL. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY.
GROUP OF NEXT TO IT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ADDRESS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MATTER CHOI FOR
US TOGETHER ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT SUBJECT THAT I WANTED
TO SAY THAT. THEY'RE SITTING
HERE LISTENING TO TESTIMONY AND-
THE SUBJECT OF PUBLIC LAW TO
EIGHTY- CONSISTENTLY HAS COME
UP HI TO SHARE THAT THE FIRST
TIME I SET FOOT IN THIS
BUILDING I WAS AN INTERN FOR
THE CABAZON BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS. AND WE WERE LOBBYING
IN TWO THOUSAND ONE FOR SENATE
BILL NINE ELEVEN SENATOR
RICHARD A LOT OF GOING BILL.
DEALING WITH TRIBAL JUSTICE
DEALING WITH- PUBLIC LAW TO
EIGHTY AND WHAT I REMEMBER WAS
HOW DIFFICULT OF A BATTLE THAT
WAS WITHIN TRIBAL. COUNTRY AND
WITHIN LAW ENFORCEMENT
STATEWIDE TO- DEAL WITH THE
UNCERTAINTY AND THE CLARITY OF
BOUNDARIES WHEN IT COMES TO
JURISDICTIONAL. ENFORCEMENT ON
IN INDIAN COUNTRY AND TODAY
RIGHT THAT CONSISTENTLY- I WAS
BROUGHT UP WHEN IT COMES TO.
WHO'S IN CHARGE OF THE
INVESTIGATING AND PROSECUTING
AND DETERMINING THE SOURCE OF
THE PROBLEMS THAT ARE REALLY AT
THE CORE OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
HERE WITH- MISSING YOUNG LADIES
AND WOMEN IN INDIAN COUNTRY.
AND I KNOW HOW DIFFICULT- THAT
ISSUE WAS THEN AND CAN IMAGINE
HOW DIFFICULT IT WOULD BE TODAY
TO TACKLE THAT. BUT CERTAINLY
SOMETHING FOR US TO CONSIDER-
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MANAGER-
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS
ISSUE OF ADDRESSING- MISSING
INDIGENOUS YOUNG LADIES AND
WOMEN WE HAVE TO GET TO. THE
CORE OF WHO IS IN CHARGE OF
FOLLOWING THROUGH. WITH THE
CRIMINAL SIDE OF THE WORK- BUT
BEFORE THAT I RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE IS A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
WORK TO BE DONE IN TERMS OF
RECOGNIZING- THE ROOT CAUSES-
GOING BACK. TO MUCH OF WHAT'S
BEEN TALKED ABOUT TO DATE AS IT
RELATES TO RECOGNIZING THE
HISTORY- THAT HAS- REALLY
CAUSED. A LOT OF THIS PAIN AND
SUFFERING OF OUR NATIVE
AMERICAN BROTHERS AND SISTERS
UP AND DOWN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT I'M I'M SITTING
HERE LISTENING TO THE
DISCUSSION AND THINKING BACK
OF. WHETHER HOW MUCH WORK-
REMAINS TO BE DONE- OR REALLY
HOW MUCH. HAS NOT CHANGED. WHEN
IT COMES TO CERTAIN ISSUES.
RELATED TO OUR NATIVE AMERICAN
BROTHERS AND SISTERS HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO I
JUST WANTED TO MENTION THE
ISSUE OF PUBLIC LAW TO EIGHTY
AND THEN PERHAPS THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO ROLL
UP OUR SLEEVES. AND WITH OUR
NEW ATTORNEY GENERAL AND MAYBE
YOU KNOW TAKE TAKE ANOTHER STAB
AT THIS ISSUE AND- AND WORK
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT UP AND
DOWN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I
BELIEVE THERE'S A- UP A NEW-
TONE. WHEN IT COMES TO LAW IN
CALIFORNIA THERE IS A DESIRE TO
TAKE A DIFFERENT APPROACH- WHEN
IT COMES TO- JUSTICE I'D LIKE
TO BELIEVE THAT GIVEN THE
VOTERS A DESIRE TO MOVE IN A
DIFFERENT DIRECTION- A NEW
APPROACH FROM DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS AND SHERIFFS THAT ARE
BEING ELECTED UP AND DOWN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA INCLUDING.
OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT THAT
THERE MAY BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TAKE A DIFFERENT APPROACH AT
THIS AND SO I JUST WANTED TO
PUT THAT ON THE TABLE AND- JUST
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE TESTIMONY
THAT WE'VE HEARD TODAY IN THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR BRINGING US
TOGETHER- MADAM CHAIR AND
MISTER CHAIRMAN- ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT SUBJECT. LAST
COMMENT. VERY PROUD TO
REPRESENT A NUMBER OF- TRIBAL
NATIONS IN MY DISTRICT STARTING
WITH THE I WILL TELL YOU IN THE
BAND OF CAHUILLA INDIANS ALL
THE WAY DOWN TO THE CATCH ON-
PEOPLE IN THE- IMPERIAL COUNTY-
SOLD THANK YOU AGAIN FOR LONG
ME TO SAY A FEW WORDS. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER- GARCIA-
NEXT WE'LL GO TO ASSEMBLY WOMAN
AGUIAR-CURRY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU FOR PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST.
AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA- A-
I'M SITTING HERE REFLECTING ON
WHAT I HEARD TODAY AND I WANT
TO THANK OF YOU FOR- TIME
SHARING YOUR STORIES- BUT I
THINK ABOUT- MOST OF OUR TIME
BULL AREAS ARE IN RURAL AREAS.
L. BRINGS TO MIND IS THE LACK
OF POLICE FORCE OUT IN THAT
AREA IF THERE WAS AN EMERGENCY
OR TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND- I
KNOW THAT I'M SURE I'M NOT
SPEAKING FOR THE- SURE FROM
HUMBOLDT COUNTY BUT I'M SURE HE
ONLY HAS A HANDFUL OF
SHERIFF'S. YOU MAY ONLY HAVE
ONE OR TWO SHOWS ON DUTY IN THE
EVENING OVER A LARGE RANGE OF
AREA. I CAN GUARANTEE YOU THAT
UNLIKE COUNTY THEY ONLY HAVE A
COUPLE PEOPLE ON ON SITE. AND A
WHOLE EVENING AND A BIG LARGE
COUNTY. SO SOMEONE WANT TO
REFLECT ON AS TO HOW CAN WE
MAKE SURE WE RESPOND AND HELP
OUR TRIBES. I'M DOING THE MOST
IMPORTANT TIMES- IN. A
DIFFICULT TIMES WHEN THEY'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT OF WHERE
THEY GO TO AND ARE THEY GOING
TO GET ANY KIND OF RESPONSE IF
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT- AGAIN I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL I WANT TO
THANK THEM ADJOURNMENT WOMAN
TRIP UP. YOU MADE A REALLY GOOD
COMMENT THAT I LEARNED A LOT.
OF DURING MY TIME HERE IS THAT
WE NEED MORE CULTURAL AWARENESS
IS HOW WE WORK WITH OUR TRIBES
AND I THINK THERE'S- OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS WELL AS OUR-
NONPROFITS NEED TO UNDERSTAND
HOW WE WORK BETTER WITH- OUR
TRIBAL. OF FRIENDS SO THANK YOU
SO VERY MUCH FOR TESTIFYING
TODAY THANK YOU FOR THIS TODAY.
BUT I THINK THERE'S MANY THINGS
WE NEED TO- DISCUSS. AS WE TRY
TO HELP OUT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU ASSEMBLY- NEXT
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS.
THANK YOU CHAIR ALMOST AND
SHERILYN GARCIA- WHAT
INFORMATION TODAY AND A LOT OF
THINGS I THINK THAT THE GENERAL
PUBLIC JUST. KIND OF THE-
DOESN'T SEE DOESN'T COME TO THE
FOREFRONT THAT THAT WERE ABLE
TO NOW DO THIS WITH BRINGING
THESE COMMITTEES TOGETHER WITH
BRINGING THE SELECT COMMITTEE.
TO GATHER- I AT THE BUSINESS
CHAIR KNOWS- I REPRESENT THE
BISHOP SHOSHONE. OUT OF INYO
COUNTY AND BE- TULIO CUT- IN
TULARE COUNTY AND WE HAVE THESE
ISSUES WE HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS BUT- I THINK SOME
OF THE THINGS WE NEED TO LOOK
AT AS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER
ADMISSION SOME OF THESE PENAL
CODES. THERE'S NOT ENOUGH TEETH
IN THESE THESE PEOPLE EVEN IF
WE ARE TO TRACK THEM DOWN TO
CATCH THEM. THEY GET RELEASED.
AND SO THERE THERE'S THINGS AND
OPPORTUNITIES WE HAVE. IT
OBLIGATIONS THAT WE HAVE TO GO
IN AND LOOK AT SOME OF THESE
THINGS AGO NO THIS IS NOT OKAY
AND THIS IS GOING TO STOP. AND
WE'RE GOING A. AS. CECILIA JUST
MENTIONED. WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
ON THE ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM.
THAT OUR PARTNERS YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE WE DO ALL THIS WORK
TO DO THESE ANIMAL USE. WITH
OUR SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT IN TO
UNDERSTAND THESE THINGS. BUT
THESE ARE RURAL AREAS. VERY
VERY MANY OF THEM. ARE
EXTREMELY RURAL AREAS. SHOAL.
IF WE DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
TRACK DURING THOSE HIGH. HERE
IT'S TO KEEP AN EYE OUT TO MAKE
SURE. THAT OUR YOUTH ARE
GETTING SNATCHED UP IN THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THE PEOPLE THEY'RE
KEEPING THAT AND I'D LIKE TO
PROTECT THEM. WHAT ARE WE
REALLY DOING AND- BECAUSE WE
CAN WE CAN PROVIDE TO THE POINT
WHERE HAVING HEARING AIDS BUT
WE CAN HAVE HEARING AFTER
HEARING AFTER HEARING WE HAVE
TO ACT. AND WE HAVE THE STOP
THE NONSENSE AND PROTECT OUR
PEOPLE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS FROM.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO COMMENT.
THANK YOU I'M GONNA CLOSE
REMARKS. THE I JUST WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE HAS BEEN A VERY
IMPACTFUL- CARRYING. HEARING
ARE SOME OUR PANELISTS TALK
ABOUT HOW OUR COMMUNITIES AND
OUR TRIBAL NATIONS ARE WOMEN
AND CHILDREN HAVE BEEN TREATED
AS FASTER EXTRA SORRY REYES AND
TOSSED AWAY. NINE SAYS OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY WE HAVE TO
CORRECT THESE WRONGS- AND SO I
KNOW AT TIMES THE WORK SEEMS
DAUNTING AND OVERWHELMING BUT
WE NEED TO START SOMEPLACE AND
THAT WORK HAS STARTED. WITH
BOTH AB THIRTY NINETY NINE WITH
THIS HEARING WITH ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AND- THAT IS NORTH THAT
WE NEED TO DO. BUT KEEP IN MIND
THAT IT SHOULD BE AS WE'VE BEEN
TOLD NUMEROUS TIME AND A GREAT
WAY THAT IT COULD LEAD
CONSULTATION AND WITH CONSENT
OF OUR- OUR TRIBAL NATIONS AND
SO LOOK FORWARD TO THAT WORK
AND I DO APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND THE LEADERSHIP
OF. OUR CHAIR OF FOR THIS
NATIVE AMERICAN CAUCUSES HELLO
COMMITTEE MR JAMES TRAVELS A TO
WORK WITH YOU ARE WOMEN'S CLUB
IS COMMITTED TO THAT AND WHEN I
THINK ALL THE MEMBERS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THIS AS WELL-
IT'S BEEN VERY VERY
INFORMATIONAL AND I LOOK.
FORWARD TO DOING THE WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE TO CORRECT
THESE INJUSTICES. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT AND
THANK YOU TO ALL THE-
PRESENTERS IN THE TESTIMONY
THOSE PROVIDED ON ZOOM. AND
HERE IN PERSON. ESPECIALLY
THOSE CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR
THESE ISSUES YOU SEE THAT. THE
VOICE OF THE CALIFORNIA PEOPLE
ISN'T JUST FALLING ON DEAF EARS
ANYMORE. CERTAINLY TWO THOUSAND
ONE WAS A DIFFERENT TIME THE
LEGISLATURE WAS DIFFERENT. THE
LEGISLATURE TODAY. IS WELL
DIVERSE AND- WORKING TOGETHER
TO BRING THE VOICE OF THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE FORWARD. AS
WE MENTIONED PRIOR THESE ARE
NOT NEW ISSUES TO THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE. WHAT'S NEW
NOW IS THAT THE ADVOCACY HAS.
EXTENDED BEYOND INDIAN COUNTRY.
INTO ALLIES THAT YOU SEE ALONG
THIS DIESS. THAT NOW WILL TAKE
UP THAT MANTLE THAT MANTLE FROM
THE WOMAN'S CLOCK IS TO SAY
THAT. MISSING AND MURDERED AND
ABUSES OF INDIAN WOMEN ON
RESERVATIONS. IN URBAN
COMMUNITIES WILL NOT BE
TOLERATED. THESE ARE THE ISSUES
THAT WE'RE MOVING FORWARD WITH
TODAY. SALAS THANK EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU FOR BEING HERE
TODAY AND IT'S BEEN MENTIONED.
THAT TODAY'S NOT JUST A DAY TO
HIGHLIGHT A BILL OR HIGHLIGHT
THESE ISSUES. TODAY'S THE DAY
THAT WE START THE HEAVY LIFTING
TO ENSURE THAT THESE THINGS.
AFTER FIVE YEARS TEN YEARS ARE
NOT- REPEATING THEMSELVES AND
WE'RE NOT SITTING HERE TODAY.
AND TO BE ABLE TO BE MORE
PROACTIVE. TO THOSE CASES
BEFORE THEY EVEN BECOME. A
MISSING OR MURDERED INDIGENOUS
WOMEN ARE PERSON WITHIN THE
TRAVEL COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THE PREVENTIVE
MEDICINE IS SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO WORK ON. IN HEARING THE
TESTIMONY FROM THE- SHERIFF OF
HUMBLE COUNTY WHO IS. THE STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION TRAVEL
LEYVA SONS. WERE ABLE TO BRING
ALL EVERYBODY TOGETHER TO START
TO WORK ON THESE ISSUES. THEN
AGAIN THAT HAS BEEN SILENT FOR
OVER A HUNDRED SEVENTY YEARS.
NOW WE'RE TAKING UP THAT MANTLE
TOGETHER IN UNITY. TOGETHER ON
THIS DIRE IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT VOICE IS BEING HEARD. I
WANT TO THANK EACH AND EVERYONE
OF YOU FOR ATTENDING. AND OFFER
YOUR TESTIMONY INTO MY- FOR
FORWARD TO STAND SIDE BY SIDE
WITH US AS WE TACKLE THESE
TOUGH ISSUES THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED. THANK YOU RIGHT.